Yeah.
Beautiful.
Uh,
we got snow flakes up in
this motherfucker. Jamie.
We are live, we are live, have naf.
Years ago today snowflakes were in the
house so we figured Brian and I were
talking the other day and I was thinking
that like one of the things that we
always, like we always said,
oh we didn't talk about this.
Oh we didn't talk about that.
He's always episodes where whatever
subject we get into with the guest,
like it doesn't, we don't, sometimes we
miss like crazy fucking stories that we,
if we had more time we'd talked about,
so we decided to do a show just dedicated
only to crazy shit that we see online
with no guests. Old School,
old school, snowflake style.
Sometimes you get away from
what got you to the dance
and there was like a thing
that happened like that.
We didn't talk about the Paris Hilton
video where he, she was on a plane.
It's like if we just brought that up,
cause I knew I had this whole theory
where that was not real. You know,
like why was her face not blurred?
And Brian is the best person I know about
calling bullshit about videos online.
Hands down. No one comes close. You've,
you've nailed so many fucking people that
are bullshitting online to hilarious.
Like everybody buys into it.
Me included.
I buy into a lot of them
and then you're like,
I think it's bullshit in my car man.
You're always fucking skeptical.
It turns out to be bullshit.
It sucks to be me though because I see
it on Facebook and I see a post like
things posted for years like and a half
to go to each one like fig and hey,
did you see the one recently where
the guy, a cat runs out into traffic.
So the guy runs after the cat
and does flips over cars now,
but I'm sure that it's so
fake. If you seen a jammy no.
Oh see if you can find it.
Cause it's preposterous.
The people were actually believing the
guy jumps over a speeding car in the
highway and then does a
flip over another car.
But it doesn't even look
like he misses the car.
It's like really shitty the way it's done.
Cause like that's he fucked up with
the flip. Like if he just did the jump,
maybe people would have believed it
because the jump luck looks almost real.
That he actually might've jumped
over the roof of a fucking car.
Does any of these thumbnails, uh, well
if I can do this, maybe it was it work?
Any of these thumbnails? Nope.
Nope. Nope. No, no, no, no,
no, no. I okay. It usually
gets run over by a car. No,
just a lot of horrible videos we put
[inaudible] it's a dude jumps over car.
How about Jude jumps over car to save
cat cat over car to that whole cat.
Kitty car Joe. Yeah, that's right. The
Lawful Kitty cat card jump. That's it.
Top One.
Watch this guy now watch this shit.
Come on.
[inaudible]
dangerous look both ways.
Probably cross the street. Yeah.
This is the straight youtube video.
I know exactly how they did.
[inaudible] I can recreate that
dangerous look both ways
before you cross the street.
This is amazing that something like that,
which would allow for that.
Something that would have been like an
insane movie special effect just 20 years
ago now you could do it on your laptop
and that's not even what you do.
You can just, it's not like,
it's not like you know you're,
you're a special effects guy. Yeah. Crazy.
The technology that's available to the
average person today is just off the
charts crazy.
One of my first special effects I
learned how to do is recording something.
You could just record yourself sitting
down like at a table and then you could
just sit there and be like,
act like you're talking to somebody to
the right of you and then you get up and
then you just sit on the other side of
the table and go, oh thank you very much.
Awe.
And they just split in the middle and
then put the two together and it's about
this being that there's like a
moving camera. Well with this,
what they probably do at this,
they probably had two cameras,
probably Gopros or something like that,
sitting right next to each other and
they recorded it at the same time.
But also they put them on like
a rack or something maybe.
So they're both on the same plane or what
they probably did is they filmed it as
if a while the cars were going,
the cars were just driving by and then
they kind of like put him into it using,
uh Oh, I see. Okay. So they film it.
The cars are driving by and
then when there's no cars,
then he runs out and jumps. The
camera never moves. Yeah. Yeah.
So the camera does move while
he's running. Shake, shake,
camera shake. Yeah, we can add that.
Yeah. That's so weird. It's, it's,
I mean,
I'm not doubting it at all,
but I'm just saying it's so weird
that you could do it so well.
The only thing that really fucks
it up is when he does the flip,
because the flip is just, you're
retarded. Yeah. That's just ridiculous.
You're just peeing in my face.
You know? It's just like before.
Then when he jumps over the car,
if he just did that and grabbed the cat
and then was like holy shit and then
stayed in the medium for a second,
you might almost believe that he did that.
Why wouldn't they just have it be
something so amazing and simple instead of
like, cause everyone's going to see
that go. That's fake as fuck. You know?
Not everyone, man. There's, there's some
fucking people out there. Yeah, true.
The guy jumping over the Lamborghini a
couple of years ago and then Kobe Bryant
did it and then everybody recreated it.
Oh Coby Brian. But he'd do it for real.
I don't think anybody
really did it for real.
So they have the car coming at those
age jumping over and Aston Martin or
something like that might come. Or the
baby they got picked up by the bird.
That's another fake one that a lot of
people I see on Facebook all the time
where it's like a some babies and this
huge like bird comes over and picks
up the baby and drops it. Like,
have you seen that? No, I
haven't. That's, that's uh,
well that's one that everyone's
still thinks to today is real.
But it ended up being a college and that
was like one of their finals that to
make that video, like making it viral,
crazy thing to go to school for,
make a viral video of bullshit
viral video. Egal picks up
babies who the eagle swooping in
and snatches is,
yeah. Oh my God. Here's
the thing though, Dude.
An Eagle would definitely do that.
I mean that just,
it doesn't happen very often because
eagles are probably scared of people and
they stay clear.
But it's not like we have some fucking
secret friendship with the eagles.
I had a f I feel fed a chicken this
weekend. It's kind of a fucked up story.
But my kids found a wounded
hawk and so they, um,
they found this wounded hawk in the
yard and so they brought the hawk,
the Hawk to this, uh, like wildlife
rescue center. But before they did,
they had to feed it and the heart
couldn't fly. So what they fed it,
mice and they got mice
from the pet store and um,
they got these little, the thing they
call pinkies, it's really fucked up dude.
It's, it's a baby mouse. It was really,
the whole thing was very creepy.
A little pink ones. Yeah. And
so I was like, okay. So they,
they fed him a certain amount of them.
They had one of them that was still alive.
They had one of them that was left.
This is like a terror movie, right.
So I come home after this weekend on
the road and to discover that they have
this little baby mouse that they haven't
fed the Hawk because they brought the
hoc to a veterinarian. The veterinarian
takes it to some, you know,
place where they take care
of wounded animals like that.
But now we have this, uh,
this baby pinky that will die.
It will die of starvation.
If you don't do anything,
you can't feed it. I mean,
it would have to milk you beating with,
I don't know what the fuck you would do.
It's so small.
It needs its mother or you bring it
back to the pet store where they're just
going to feed it to a snake, right? So I
said, I'll just give it to the chickens.
That's hard to watch,
right? That's a baby feel,
dude.
It's like life is fucked.
It's crazy how ruthless life is,
you know? And I didn't have like,
my decision was is this, this thing's
going to die or it's going to die.
So I'm going to take the responsibility
away from my hands and and to bring it
to a place where it's going to die,
it's probably already starving to death
because they had it for like over a day
with no food. I'm like, this is so crazy.
But it's like we decide that there's like,
I don't know if it's a meritocracy,
what would you call that?
There's like a hierarchy of animals.
There's a hierarchy of value and we
value the life of this wounded hawk more
than this baby mouse.
And when I fed it to the chickens had
all came in to play in such a weird,
obvious way that this is life.
Like that little thing was huge
and my chickens are not that cute.
They're not that cute. I mean, they're
beautiful. They're interesting animals,
but they don't have a
sense of like this little
tiny little thing did.
But I fed that tiny little thing
to those chickens and it was like,
I don't think, I don't know if I did the
right thing. Like I don't know if they,
in first of all the chickens,
that thing wasn't even on the ground
for a second and I mean us second before
they mauled it. It was, they are
Goddamn Raptors. They're dinosaurs.
There is chickens are Goddamn
Jurassic Park. We're just really big.
So chickens don't do anything but they've
pecked at my daughter's before they'll,
they'll check to see if they can eat you,
you know,
they see you might be vulnerable,
you might be soft. Oh,
she thought your foot was a warm nope.
She probably was wondering
whether or not shake it, eat you.
That's really what the fuck was going on.
She probably wasn't thinking you were
a bug. Chickens are fucking monsters.
They're just little monsters. So you can
grab those little fuckers. And you know,
I was hanging out with this finks
cat all week and I was babysitting.
My friends thinks and it's amazing how
different that kind of breed of cat is to
a normal cat. This cat
is like a real cat. They,
it's almost like a feral animal.
Like it would come big come up to me,
just grab a Bagel off my plate and go,
this is mine. And they run away and,
and this is just a kid and I'm like,
what the fuck are you to like
it just steal from you. Yeah.
And it's theirs. They're hotter than a
normal cat so they're like really hot.
And so you will wake up in the
morning and you'll think, oh my God,
who am I sleeping up next to? And it's
a cat. It's, Whoa, they're hotter.
They're hotter and a half. They like
to snuggle cause they have no first.
So it's like if anyone's depressed
by when he's catchy, you get,
get a few of them,
you can line them all up.
You feel like that you're sleeping with
the person. It's, it's a crazy cat though.
It's,
it's an interesting cat
swing a cat without any hair
and sing their wrinkles in
their face, I guess. Yeah. It's
almost like a little thing.
It's not like a cat.
Right?
Like when you think of any mammal that
you keep as a pet would have for when you
have a pet that doesn't have further,
that's when shit gets real. Yeah.
You've got this weird ratcat thing
that needs to cuddle with you. Ooh,
look at his face or her face it cut.
It'll go right up to my dog is bite
in the ass and then run it away.
It's a big animal, man. Yeah.
You know what's really crazy is
those serve walls. Let's see.
We'll have those circles is that
is what they have the, the bangles.
What are the ones that
people have as pets?
Like I know Jon Jones as a couple of them.
They'd tear shit up though.
I don't believe in decline.
Your cabinet.
I think if you have one of those
you have to write or, yeah,
that's a real cat that lives in
your house. Yeah, they're big.
I don't know if it's a all
it feels like that's too big.
I think that might be one of those
ones that they have in Africa,
but you don't like get as pets here
but there's ones you can get as pets in
America that are just fucking,
it might be called a survival.
But there there's these
Cheyenne ass fucking things man.
And look at the size of that thing
with that little girl. And by the way,
like if you have food
and you give them food,
they growl and hiss while
they're eating the food.
Like if you give them like a chicken,
like
some dude at a video of him
online, um, feeding his,
one of those kinds of
cats. And I was like, wow.
He was feeding it chicken
wings and it was just,
it's so like close.
They're so close to like a wildcat,
like are even a regular cat is pretty
fucking wild. They can get pretty wild.
You know, regular cats all kill
every regular cat you have.
You leave them outside with like
a bird or something like that,
they're going to fuck that bird up.
They just kill
are cat fights in Hollywood all the time?
Oh Dude.
He's probably not even a cat fight.
It's probably a girl getting our cat
vagina ripped open by those fangs.
Did you see this? This is a, a a guy,
a couple of guys that have a tiger
that just living at their house.
I just thought it was funny because,
uh,
wow.
Whoa.
Jesus Christ.
Huh?
Listen to what they're watching. They're
watching some Joe Rogan shit on the TV.
These guys just have a tiger for a pet.
This is the most retarded shit ever.
Look how cute it is.
It's adorable.
Okay.
Where is this APP?
It doesn't say in the description.
It's for folks who are watching
or listening and not watching.
This is a probably like a, it's not a huge
cat, but it's probably like 300 pounds,
right? Yeah. I would say it's
about the size of a mastiff. Yeah.
It would have to have really big
mastiff. It's, it seems like, okay.
Let's say at least 200 plus
pounds, right? At two 50 yeah. Oh,
more than that probably. Yeah. Okay.
Let's call it whatever we were counting,
what am I doing here?
But just it's going to get bigger and
if it decides to kill you, it just does.
It's surprising.
It's surprising how often people can
have those cats and it'd be safe though.
I'll tell you that.
It is surprising.
You think about how many knuckleheads
have fucking pet tigers and lions and
check. Gregor wants to get one supposedly.
Oh Connor, please don't do that.
Please don't make me talk about
you in my act. If you get eaten,
I will have to sir, I love and respect
to you, but did you get eaten by a lion?
I'm going to talk about you on a pug.
Just hanging out like bored as fuck.
Wishing I could run outside
and kill things. That's
the thing about those animals is they
have these built in things like a man has
or a woman has like a woman has a
built in desire, at least most of them.
I don't want to assume that you don't
for wanting some sort of sexual contact.
Almost everyone does. Right?
And almost everyone has a,
this, this desire to be a part
of the same sort of social group.
It's always existed, uh, with our
species. You know, towns and groups,
these animals have always hunted.
That's been a part of their life
for as long as there've been tigers.
I don't know how long it's, I
mean, Gee, I don't, I have no idea.
It's got to be thousands and
thousands of generations.
Who knows how many fucking years
tigers had been around the form.
They're in the now and all
that time they'd been killing,
kill, kill, kill, kill,
eat,
eat.
It's so arrogant to think that you
could just take them and turn them into
golden labs. You just, that's so,
that's crazy thinking.
It's so silly and it's not
healthy for the animal.
That would be like taking a person who
grew up in like rural Ohio and making
them live as a Bushman in Africa.
You know,
just taking them to some place where
guys have spears and they have to hunt
lions to become a man. And you wouldn't
be prepared for that kind of Shit.
Neither of these people
prepared to or neither is.
There's this tiger rather
prepared to live with people.
It's hold its design.
Its whole existence has been
to kill up until this moment.
This is big cat Derek. We've talked
about him a few times on that.
We need to get this dude on.
He trains these things. Yeah,
he lives in Texas and next time we go
to Texas. Do you know, I mean this is,
I I've, there's, there's
thousands of tigers in Texas.
Tigers in Texas are like super common
sit because of the weather is or I think
it's because Texas has crazy wildlife
laws. I have a whole bit about it.
It's great. They have weird laws.
I W I wouldn't mind having a Lama.
Are you living on a lama? They
get, see mama fine. Steve Rinell,
his brother has lamas that he takes to
a hunt with them and he packs the lamas
out because llamas are like more durable
than horses. They don't get cold.
They just stand outside in the snow.
They don't give a fuck.
Like it doesn't even bother them.
Like you're freaking out and shivering.
The Lama doesn't give a shit.
Have you ever thought about upgrading
your a little pet farm? You know,
you've got chickens like get a little
baby goats. Baby goats would be amazing.
I have baby go to be cute.
Yeah, I think, um, it's,
it would be really hard to have a baby
goat if you eight goats goat. You know,
like if you have a baby sheep and the
new ate lamb, you'd be like, okay,
what are we doing here? You know,
I tell you, man, I've been hunting,
I've been fishing.
Uh,
I've seen animals killed that thing
yesterday with that little pinky mouse
disturbed me as much as
anything I've ever seen. Well,
maybe you were supposed to save it.
Maybe that's the whole thing.
And we're thinking he's going to raise it,
eat it.
No one had to bring it
back to a pet store.
And then that guy would have fed it to
snakes. That's what they sell them for.
They sell them t to feed snakes
with snakes. First of all,
I'm not saying you shouldn't have a snake.
Don't get me wrong.
Have you love snakes? I'm
not saying you're wrong. If
you love whatever you love,
you love, as long as you have a pet
snake and that snake doesn't need a baby,
you're allowed to love that pet snake,
but the reality is that pet's neck,
that fucking thing would
eat a baby at any chance.
If you left a baby alone with a giant
Anaconda is going to eat that baby 100% of
the time,
a hundred percent one
zero zero fucking evil.
They don't give a fuck.
They don't care.
They don't have like a deep attachment
to you because you feed them.
There are snakes as it is a very
insane animal to keep as a pet.
I, but I understand it. I totally
understand it. They're beautiful.
They're amazing and fascinating and you
do get like an electrical feeling when
you watch snakes move around.
You get this field because there's like
this primal fear that you have of snakes
and when you have a snake as a pet,
it's like it ignites all these
little primal triggers in your body.
Your body's not your body.
To him.
Why we were we friends with is we
make it an alliance with the enemy.
Yeah.
My friend,
the snake and it wraps his arms or fucking
body rather around your neck and your
arms and you don't, you don't, you're
not afraid. Why are you not afraid?
You don't think there's
that one vegetarian snake,
the one snake that would try to be a good
dewar or did you see this video today?
I don't even talk.
There are vegetarian snakes.
You see this video of a dog trying to
save a fish's life though it really made
me go,
how is this possible that this dog
knows to try to save this fish is light.
So he's sitting here like,
uh,
just putting water on on
the fish and then he goes,
it really is, it's on live
leak. Well, you've got it on
Youtube. It's from lively.
Yeah, but it says dog
tries to save a fish. Yeah.
He's literally trying to get water on it
and then he's fucking goes to another
fish and actually saves this Fisk the fish
that comes back to life a little and
so crazy. How does he know to do it?
He's fucking his nose up
too. That's gotta suck. Yeah.
Like he's checked to see if it's still
alive. Is that giving CPR to a fish?
Is that a golden lab?
It looks like no,
it looks like more of a point
year title type of an animal.
It's like one of those Japanese
mixed with without cause she,
you mixed with a retriever.
Maybe
like maybe a Shiba Inu. Yeah.
Yeah. That's weird man. There's,
there's an intelligence that
animals have a very bizarre,
so I mean like we kind of think that the
only way to know things is someone has
to teach you them. That's kind of
how human beings have, we, we've,
we've sort of accepted
that as just a fact.
The only way to know something
is if someone teaches you.
But there's a lot of shit
you know, that, you know,
like are a lot of reactions that you have
that are, that are built in like, um,
Rupert Sheldrake.
Cause the guy's been on the podcast
before and he had this excellent analogy
about, um, what children in, um,
big cities are afraid of.
And that they're afraid of scary monsters,
even though they don't
have a reference point.
They didn't never really seen a monster,
but they're afraid of scary monsters.
And I believe I might be butchering this,
but I think his supposition
was that what's going on
is that they have this fear
that's built in from back when they
were little monkeys from when they were
hiding from like leopards and Jaguars.
These,
these beasts set would have
dark teeth or you know,
bright white teeth and they would be dark
and he would hide the night and try to
get you,
you know, cause that probably
really happened at one point.
There was probably this animal
that hunted in the darkness, right?
And it killed a lot of the ancestors of
all the people and somehow or another
that's in our system,
somehow or another,
it's built in like when animals know
that they should be breastfeeding.
But that's all built in. Like there's
all these reward systems and is,
there's all these things built in to
make sure that you continue the same
behavior,
the releasement of oxytocin or though
the love feeling that you have with
comrades and friends and family.
Like why is all that stuff there?
It's all that is built in to make
sure that we keep moving forward.
So we think that there's,
that's all, that's where all
our information comes from.
All information comes
from human knowledge.
All our information comes from the
things that we've written down,
the things that we've learned
about the way we behave.
I think some of it is in the bones.
I think some of it is deepen the bones.
Like it's almost like you're born with
a certain amount of information. Cat,
cat litter box. Yeah.
I mean you're a baby,
a cat litter box when you had cats pretty
much know what a cat litter boxes from
being a kitten. And it's like,
wait, you're such a baby.
But somehow we put a box down with
some weird shit in it, you know,
to go in that box and then cover
it up and it's weird. Yeah,
that's a good point. Yeah. That's a real
good point there. It's built into them.
Yeah. And there's this the case with a
lot of different behavior that we see in
nature. Right? Almost
all of it. Instinctual.
There's a few learned moments.
Like one of the things that I
saw that was fascinating was um,
orcas trying to teach
their young how to hunt.
They're teaching their young how to
turn over ice islands so that they would
make the seals slip down into their
mouths and they would put these seals back
up and they'd do it all over again.
And I was like, Whoa, this is fucked.
Was the seals are penguins, one of
those. Um, but when they did it,
it was so obvious that they were teaching
their teaching their little babies.
Like, Whoa, they're teaching them
tactics. But that's just like people,
you have to learn like hunting tactics.
You have to learn to stay away though,
you know,
you can't have the wind in your face.
That means the animals you're
looking at or the wind behind you,
I mean is animals you will,
you're looking at,
it's going to be in their face so they're
going to smell you like there's all
these things they have to learn. Okay,
got it. I teach you, but how much of an,
how much do you have to
tell them to actual hunt?
Like how much is that as in like,
uh,
like some sort of a memory system
that there's a reward for doing that.
Like you ever go fishing? Yeah. You like
that feeling. It's awesome. It's great.
Except for taking the thing out of the
fish. It's grass does not literally,
but you know that feeling that
you get when you catch a big fish,
like a good fish that you can eat like a
real one. You're like, well I'll ride to,
we're the fucking eat this fish now.
It's like this weird primal sort
of response thing that we don't,
for whatever reason,
don't talk about it.
But that's why it's fun to even
catch and release fish. You know?
Like Ari and I were in a Alaska and there,
there was like a point in time while we
were there where you could only catch
and release because they had this,
um,
they have this like cutoff point where
if you don't have a certain amount of
salmon going through the weird,
they worry that the numbers
might be low right then,
which is so crazy because they may,
if you catch and release like the
chances of you harming the animal is like
pretty fucking high.
It's like the chances of the
animal actually living is probably,
people don't want to say it,
but I researched it after we did the trip
and there were thinking that probably
should have researched it
before we did the trip.
But they were thinking that like maybe
as many as 20% of all the fish that you
catch and release wind up dying. Oh yeah.
They get fucked up from those hooks,
which totally makes sense.
Right.
But if you just make them see
if they could keep one fish,
which is like they usually do,
and king salmon fishing,
you would catch one and you would keep
that one and that one would die and
that's all you would be able to fish for
it. You'd have to stop unless you keep,
you can keep one and do catch and release,
which is catch and release
is kind of bullshit.
Yeah, cause it's pretty much you're just
getting a shotgun to the face and go.
Hopefully you live,
because I know Barb,
a giant as Barb hooked into your face.
Yeah,
I catch and release is kind of bullshit
and that's the only way I've actually
fish. I've never actually fixed
where I was allowed to eat the fish,
these guys to saving a hammerhead
shark. Hammerhead sharks. Okay.
Here's another hierarchy.
Example.
Hammerhead sharks are
cooler than regular sharks.
I'd be way more likely to
save a hammerhead shark than
a great white because his
face has already sat enough, was
kind of cool. He's like an alien.
That's crazy. Why don't they turn it over
and put it back in the water? Hook out.
Oh, it's got a hook in it. Yeah.
Oh, someone caught it? Yeah. Wow.
So did they catch it accidentally?
Mm,
well that's just part of fishing. If you
accidentally catch a shark like, well,
but,
but it's in a weird that we have this
like response that we want this thing to
live this murderous fucking feed machine.
All it does is feed and we wanted to live.
It's super bizarre.
Super Bizarre that we want that
thing to live. I had a fucking point.
What was my point about fish? Oh
that eve, there's this reward,
this instinct thing that
we have built in it.
Even when you like catch and release,
it's triggered even what it's like,
there's a trigger that makes you
want to do that and it's built.
I think it's some information that people
are born with or at least a response
to a reality that you're born with.
You know, in a very weird way,
because it used to be that x amount of
years ago and for who knows how many
thousands of generations.
That's how you made sure he stayed
alive when you caught a fish.
So it gave you like this reward
again. We got one, you know,
some fucking Gollum type shit
when he finds the ring, you know.
And even though all
these generations later,
we're still getting our fish on styrofoam
containers. When you catch a fish,
there's this weird release.
Maybe you man,
maybe there's something wrong with you.
Maybe you're just a fucking
asshole and you're like, oh fine, thanks.
I think it's amazing.
In Ohio they have a fishing,
but they have ponds like at the work,
like the workplaces,
uh,
my mom used to work at this place and
they had issue mungus ponds at lunch you
could just go and fish and you know, and
just chill out, not think about work.
But you had to uh,
you know,
throw it back in and then go back to
work in maybe you don't really see shit
like that. Like these big corporations
and stuff like that. Fishing pond, right.
They stock up with interesting fish.
Well, they do that. I think in like
when people have like a lot of money,
like down south they'll have like a lake
stocked with Bass and shit like that.
And they'll take clients to it and stuff.
I know they do that.
Like people that have a lot of money
that have um, a big corporations,
a lot of times they'll, they'll have like
a box at like say like staples center.
So anything that's playing there they
get to go see, which is kind of cool man.
Imagine if you owned like some network
or something like that and you could just
go take your friends to a button,
whatever it is. Lakers game, UFC fight,
uh, Kevin Hart's playing. There you
go see it. That's fucking baller.
That might be like ultimate baller
shit to have like a box. Is that okay?
Boxworks am I misrepresenting it?
Oh yeah. Yeah. It's a corporate,
that's how they sell the stadium stuff.
You have to buy that.
They sell all those pretty much the
tickets as well. In some cases you do,
but depending on who you are and how
big and how much money you spend on your
box. So what if you like one of those
dudes from like Microsoft? Like if you,
one of those, uh, Bruce bomber guys, like
the guy who goes crazy. Walmart owns the,
Steve Balmer owns the clippers.
Yeah.
So he owns part of the arena two
or something like that. That's,
that's high level shit.
Yeah. My owns a gun.
My friend's dad used to have out box in
Columbus, but it was Columbus clippers,
but it's Columbus clippers box
and a AAA baseball team. Really?
But you'd go there.
It was really cool.
It was like this really nice
little they had, it was catered.
They had waiters that just came
in and everything was free.
You'd just had a stocked fridge, uh,
all the hotdogs you wanted and it was
wow. That's cool. Yeah. Eddie Bravo
went to the UFC at one of those.
He has a friend who has one of those
at the staples center and I was like,
what is that? Like? He's like, dude,
it's crazy. It's all upholstered. Yeah.
Leather and hors d'oeuvres and fucking
the best beer on ice and wine and one for
Monday night.
Raw event one night.
[inaudible] we've got free tickets
because my boss at the time is his,
one of his good friend has managers,
uh, or he's the manager of John Sienna.
So we got access to the event,
but there was a cavs basketball
game going on the same night.
Some of my friends stayed in the box,
watch the TV of the basketball game,
listen to the raw going on outside,
and then when something cool came out,
we just like took two
steps and then washed it,
came back and watch the basketball game.
I need to go. I don't give a
shit enough about sports to,
to like a local follow him,
but I need to go to an event.
I need to go to like one,
like real good basketball games. Maybe.
Maybe I'll get it. I was hoping to,
calves are going to play the clippers
and talk in the sea and Lebron play this
year, but it didn't happen. God dammit.
If you want to go see Lebron play,
let's pick a spot and we'll find out
where they're going to be and we'll book a
show in that town and we'll go see Lebron.
And Cleveland is he like,
is he like the guy like the Jordan of
our generation's space jam too, right?
I can't believe I said that because this
is a running joke in the UFC because
Mike Goldberg one time asked me if
Travis looter was the Michael Jordan of
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu. And I was
like, okay, this is a, yeah, no,
but you want to see Lebron if you could
say, but just to finish my sentence,
Travis Luder is like this bad ass
American Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt.
He's like, like look super, super high
level. Like when he was in the UFC,
I was super excited because I was like,
this guy's gonna submit a lot of fucking
people that you haven't seen submitted
before. His left, his level
of Jujitsu, super high level.
But when Goldberg was saying like
the Michael Jordan of it, I was like,
that's like so cliche that people do that.
They always have to say like his,
he the tiger woods of pool
as he, the Michael Jordan
number zillion just to like,
no, he's fucking Travis. Looter
like, that's he's Badass.
That's who he is. You know?
I said the Michael Jordan of Brazilian
Jiu Jitsu is Marcello Garcia,
but that was just cause he's at the time,
at least for sure the best
and most spectacular guy.
But he's not the Michael Jordan.
He's Mike, he's Marcello Garcia.
He's his own dude. He doesn't have to be
the Michael Jordan of something. You Fox.
It's like when, when anybody tries to say
it's like our version of nigger, like,
no, it's not. No, you got
your own fucking insult.
You can say it's your version
of the n word. You just,
you're not allowed to know. It
means something bad to you. Okay.
I get it. I get it. See, I've, um,
I've fucking no tolerance for that.
What do you think about this hall?
Cogan shakes that tired.
It makes me sad.
Makes me sad that he talks like that.
That's what it makes me sad.
Hulk Hogan said a bunch of shit about his
daughter dating black guys. Like, man,
come on in 2015 or whatever the
fuck this video was years ago.
Wasn't in that sex tape.
Whatever. It's from man.
It's sad to me that he thinks like that.
It's sad. That shit's sad. It's just sad.
It's just, it's just people, man,
that guy didn't ask to be born black.
You didn't ask to be born white.
There's cool people,
cool fucking people that are black.
Um,
some of my favorite people I've
met of all time have been black.
The idea that you would be upset that
your daughter would date someone just
because they're black. To me it
makes me sad. It made me mad at him.
Maybe I'd be mad if I was black.
It makes me sad.
Makes me sad that he thinks that way.
You know? And it wasn't even funny.
It wasn't like you were saying
something funny, you know,
if he was saying something funny,
man, I'll cut him a break. You know,
maybe we try to be funny. He, he's
like, well, I, I could do some bad news.
The good news is, you know, your,
your daughter's dating a strapping
six foot four super athlete.
The bad news.
His name is Tyrone white.
And what color do you think
Tyrone? Is He a white,
he's a giant. He's black and he was
always shiny. He's like oily. He's oily.
His whole body is like slippery and
muscular and oily and he's got addicted.
It looks like an eel like an evil eel and,
and your daughter loves it.
She loves it. She's super
happy about it. Right.
Okay. I just don't, I don't, you
know, it just makes me feel sad.
I don't think he's racist though.
I think maybe this, yes. No,
what he said was racist.
Anybody that says he's not a racist.
Maybe he says things in private and he
thinks of them as being in private and he
wants some sort of escape from the PC
world that he finds himself in where he is
public, where he's public. He has
to have these cans, statements.
You never hear them swear.
You never hear him talk about anything
like controversial. He's a businessman.
He's selling whole Kogan. It's not
even his name. It's his brand. Okay.
Maybe when you live a life like that or
you're this fucking American superhero
years old, years old, you're
always doing an act. You know,
he's always whole Cogan oh, commanders
running rod bro. And I interviewed him.
I interviewed him with UFC. It was one
of my all time favorite interviews man.
Put pull that shit up. Yeah,
he was awesome cause spike
TV. Ha. It was an honor.
It really was an honor.
There's two people that I've interviewed
where I felt like, well there's a bunch.
Obviously Neil degrasse Tyson and uh,
Brian Cox.
There's a lot of people that I met
where it was an honor, but hulk Hogan,
I was like, this guy is, this is
fucking Hulk Hogan man. This is,
I'm can't believe that I've
somehow or another have a job.
No wrestlers.
Oh, time, sports and
entertainment. Huge personality.
The one and only Hulk Hogan.
Welcome aboard sir. How are you?
Thank you my brother Joe.
Man,
it doesn't get any
better than this brother.
These guys are going to war out here.
It's unbelievable.
Now you've made this an animate fights
before you a UFC fan. Oh, I'm a huge fan.
My brother.
I share him.
Now I understand that you have recently
announced a partnership with TNA
wrestling and its president Dixie Carter
and you're going to be moving this.
I'm going to see some Hulkamania on
Spike TV. Tell us more about that.
I got a ton of energy and
our partners with spike.
I'm partners with Dixie Carter.
I'm partners with TNA and we just
got the green right brother onto my,
maybe I should watch myself more because
I'm annoying. I'm annoying me right now.
Maybe I'd be less annoying if I
watched him ever. Why hate watching
Paul Coconut? TNA. We're
coming after everybody.
We're coming out for everybody now.
I understand that you have,
you recently released a book. You have,
you've done a wrestling tour in Australia.
When are we going to see Hulk Hogan
Wrestle in TNA. We'll brother.
I'm going January for luck. I said Monday
night we're going to Wharton am packs,
but you never know. I'm going over there
to take over the maniacs or common.
All the teenage brother for racist
might just Hogan is common back.
Ladies and gentlemen, TNA wrestling live
on spike TV. Hugs here for the fights.
He you want to watch them on TV?
What's you're going to do brother?
I'm on you. What are you going
to do? That's the good question.
Thank you very much sir.
Call me brother. At least a dozen
times. Yeah, that's a lot of brothers.
I'll die happy. I sat behind him
that I was there that, that that day.
And I sat behind him and I remember
the whole time he had this little comb
anyways, just combing his hair
slowly while watching the UFC.
He's put on a show man. He's
smart. Look Hulk. Here's the deal.
Hoke Hogan is still talked about today.
It's 2015 when I was in high school,
I was in high school in the 80s.
The Hawk was the fucking man. Okay.
He was a fucking man back then.
He was in rocky. Three man or
four? Three, four, three, three,
three. Which ones? The Russian. What's
four? Then four is Russia. Russia,
who's in four? No, three was
mr t and hulk Hogan. Right.
And it wasn't for, was the Russian all
you're right, you're right. You're right.
It was three, five of us and
shitty way. So those three,
I was totally in high school
cause I went with this, uh,
this chick that I was dating and
I remember it very well. Shit,
the best popes all time.
All time.
So I remember,
I remember that movie based on the
check that I want with not hilarious.
He do that you have like those
highschool moments we just like, oh yeah,
that's like
pimps are great.
So Hulk Hogan said some racist shit.
You don't have to.
Par Part of me is like, yeah,
it's sad that he thinks that
way. I don't know. Again,
if if you are black and you're angry
at it, I understand. I don't get mad.
I get sad book with that one
especially. But I, I just,
it makes me wonder how many people
talk like that when no one's around.
How many people say like racist Shit,
whether you're holding me every day.
I've talked about this all the time.
It's my favorite thing to do to animals.
Like, but no one could be around
unless I'm dating them and I just,
I use, I mean I used the f word, the
n word, like I, I just f for Gay.
The gay slur. Yeah. Cause I think
saying it till dog as well. It's,
but you're doing it for amusement.
It's funny because you don't get to say
it anymore. You're silly guy though. See,
this is the thing, you're silly. And
one of the things about you haven't,
excuse me. Pardon me. One of the
things about you is, which is funny,
is where you automatically like gravitate
towards the inappropriate shit to say
like racially, sexually, you automatically
do it. Like you can't help yourself. So,
but you're not a mean person. You
certainly aren't racist. Like I know you,
you're never ever racist. I'm never
racist. I'm just mildly joking.
It's just hilarious. It's fun.
Wrong Shit. Yeah. That's why I'm
a comic. Yeah, right.
But that's different.
Like if someone somehow or no, they're
like stuck a microphone. Your cat's ass.
Like one of those jewels
that you have in there
put on Instagram catchall
but yours. I can't believe
those are real. First of all.
Is that real? I don't think
so. You can't be kind of,
we get mad Catz not just going to walk
around with a diamond and it's as if it's
a sticker.
I was thinking that sticker might work,
but anything to cover the
butthole would be great.
They can clean their ass with their
tongue. They would feel it and clean it.
Right. Uh, not if it's
like really strong sticker
and they wouldn't give a shit,
then they would die from impact.
Did Shit. Yeah. That's, I don't know.
I had a point before all this got started.
What was the beginning of it all
taught racism saying racist shit
cause we don't get to, you know, it's,
it's fun to say Shit Racist,
not racist shit. My Shit,
we're not supposed to a Voodoo shit.
Yeah.
The differences are that they think that
like if you were saying anything that
was racist, it would be in jest
and in just doesn't bother people.
Cause they know they don't, they, you
might have to apologize, like, look,
I didn't mean for this to get public,
but I certainly said it in jest.
I was just fucking around with my friends.
I love everybody.
Then you probably could, you know,
people would accept your apology,
they'd be mad at you,
but they'd accept your apology.
But what he was sale is not
really in chest, you know,
at least it didn't seem like it.
It was just,
it was just an uncomfortable thing that,
you know,
and I don't think that the guy at work,
however old he is, 60 something years old.
I don't think he, he's
done learning. You know,
it's not like you should
just write them off.
He should just talk about
why he said it and what he,
what he you felt and you know, and then
he, sorry. I think people can accept that.
I don't think I'll glove into the bad guy.
I think sometimes people do things like
that and everybody all of a sudden is
like super mad at him. They
hate him forever. He fucked up.
You know?
That's what I think.
I think you fucked up and he fucked
up thinking like that and he probably
realizes he fucked up when he feels it.
I think it's also something though that
a lot of people have to like take their
own. Like everyone's, it's so easy to
blame or say, hey, that guy said that.
But if you were to take your
whole life and not knowing it,
your parts were recorded. Oh, you're
fucked. Everyone's fucked. We're fucked.
But it's really easy to point like, Oh,
this guy is racist, blah, blah, blah.
He's a horrible person. But like any
of us, you can take it, like you said,
put a microphone in my cats
by hole like that and, and,
and record me and take 10 seconds off
of my life and air and put it online and
I'm fucked.
Yeah. Well that's everything man.
Everything. I mean, anything you do,
if you're doing an all the time, you're
gonna make mistakes. Whether it's walking,
if someone just wanted to take clips,
are you walking into shit and
they followed you around all day?
How many times do you walk into things?
I walk into things not paying attention.
I'm talking,
I accidentally bump into a wall or I hit
a door when I didn't mean to hit a door.
It happens,
right?
But if someone just followed you all the
time and took those snippets and splice
them together and go, here's
Jamie Vernon, look at this. Fuck.
Just walking into walls everywhere
he goes. But most of the time,
the vast majority of the time,
you elegantly navigate your
way through the universe.
But the Times where you bounce
your car door off the look,
I understand if you get upset,
if somebody dings your car door,
but who the fuck hasn't
Dang someone's car door.
Please step up and raise your hand
cause I've never met this person.
I have dang people's car doors.
Okay.
And I've think people's car doors
and left a note and told them email,
email me or whatever
and I'll give you money.
It's been a long time since I did that,
but I did that. Okay, that's not true.
Wait a minute,
I didn't ding their car door accidentally
hit her bumper and I left a small mark.
Okay. I have pinged at guy's door. Not
like definitely dinged guides or not.
Now that I'm thinking about it,
the only times I've ever left a a note
of left a note at least once that I can
remember. That's not foggy. And that was
cause I think a ding there. Pumper. Yeah,
I've dinged but it didn't leave a mark
door dinner. I'm trying to think, man,
it's been a long time.
I'm super careful of it now.
But back before I was a car nut
especially I know of Dang a few doors.
I'm, I'm guilty as charged a hundred
percent. That's a fucking bad feeling.
You don't think about it. You're
like, you're in your own head.
I gotta get this done. I gotta pay
that Bill. Fuck. And then dunk.
Can't always be responsible for paying
attention. You're gonna make mistakes.
You all responsible.
I don't mean that.
What I mean is you can't be
held accountable forever.
You got to let it go at
a certain point in time.
So I think even with this hulk Hogan
Guy, he fucked up. Yeah, he fucked up.
He shouldn't. Yeah, you're right. He
definitely shouldn't think like that.
But if we had to follow you around stupid
and make a fucking clip of all your
life,
all the blunders you do in the creepy
shit you say in the weird fucking stuff,
you Google, guess what?
You're a mess to your, oh,
you're way more of a mess.
If I splice it all together and some
sort of a crazy hit real, you know,
and that's, it's easy to do for a
guy like a whole Cogan, you know,
it's easy to do. He's
public, he's so public.
He's there all the time and that's what
pretty much what TMZ does and what they
make money for it. They're
like, Hey, you know what?
We're going to go after Lindsay Lohan.
Every single thing Lindsay
Lohan or Justin Bieber does,
where we're going to make
sure everyone knows about it.
Here's my feeling about TMC and I'm
being completely honest about it.
Most of what they're doing as far as
like doing this stuff and this guy got
arrested for drunk driving and the mostly
what they're doing is making fun of
preposterous shit that we actually
probably would make fun of to like,
let's be honest, like every time
something happens like Lake Lindsay Lohan,
we can say like, oh, they
report on Lindsay Lohan,
but meanwhile we fucking talk about it.
We will talk about on this podcast if
something comes up on this podcast.
It's crazy in the news
that someone has done,
you're like shook night runs
over somebody with his truck.
We're gonna fucking talk about it and
where are we going to get our video from?
We're going to get a video from TMZ.
Everybody wants to that what they're
doing is inherently evil and I him,
man,
I'm not sure cause it seems like they
only care about stuff that's happening.
They don't have to go after people and
peer into their lives and find out who
likes strap ons and he, you know, who's
into watching weird shit. You know,
they don't have to do that because there's
so much content just by people being
ridiculous that I don't
necessarily see them as evil.
I see them as just, it's a, it's
a new segment of entertainment.
I mean there's a lot of in and stand
in front of Kanye West House taking
pictures of them and shit.
There's a lot of that stuff that goes on.
But that's just, that's happening.
He's crazy. The whole thing is crazy.
It's just crazy circus they put on, you
know, they, they did a reality show.
She did a crazy sex tape.
It's like all this stuff is generating
all this attention and someone comes in
and looks at all the attention.
He goes, look at this crazy shit.
It's pretty much what we do.
Right? Yeah. I mean, you know, we,
we might not like break the news.
We might not when we're not journalists,
but we are, I mean, what does reporting,
what does that mean? What do, what do,
what do you mean?
Are you talking about stuff or are
you just simply reporting the facts?
Cause most of those shows lay a heavy
bit of editing and the editorial review
and ideas into their pieces. You
know, even like TMZ, when they're,
they're making fun of something,
it's pretty obvious or making fun of it.
They're not reporters, you
know, what are they doing?
They're doing like some new form of
entertainment. It's not that bad.
Like everybody pretends that stuff pad.
What's just as bad as all the people.
Like when you, especially when you're
covering reality stars and, and,
and like real housewives type shit,
like none of it's bad,
but if anything's bad, it's like, what
are you, who's putting that on TV?
Like what are you doing?
Like what's that?
And if they do something crazy
and someone follows them,
the people that follow them are bad.
But you're not bad for putting these wacky
fuckers on TV and feeding him Tequila
all day and putting cameras in their
face and getting them in a position where
they hope that maybe there'll be able
to chew through their $50,000 in fucking
student debt by being an asshole on
TV and generating a following. Right.
And becoming some fucking crazy fan
favorite on the show because he's the one
who likes to throw drinks in people's
face and fucking get gangster.
You know what, who's forcing them to
do that? Well, who is it? But it's not,
the whole thing is,
is do the whole thing's a circus soda
to pick on anybody who's like looking at
the circus and commenting on
the circus as being the problem.
That seems to me to be,
that's a little disingenuous.
I could see the circus is fine.
There's nothing wrong with
like a real housewives show.
It's nothing wrong with it.
And for the people that that can
make money by being observed,
there's nothing wrong with them either.
If they're providing entertainment,
whether we want to think of it
as traditional entertainment,
like a guy who writes a book of cartoons
or art or music or anything like that,
it's still entertainment.
It might not be good in your sense,
but neither is burger king.
We don't want to put Burger King on
trial cause their cheeseburgers suck
compared to in and out.
You know
it's, we should, we should.
But I find it fascinating and Co and
it's weird that people who focus on the
circus or the people that are somehow
low lives, it's weird. Isn't that weird?
Oh yeah. Oh you're talking to Jamie.
All of you talk about it all morning.
He's been talking about Rob Schneider
getting burglarized all morning.
He got burglarized. Yeah. It's $175,000
Willie Mays baseball card was stolen.
So what they did is they, they knew he
was in Montreal. Whoever did it, you know,
for the comedy festival, he's down.
They just robbed him blind. That sucks.
That's Ugh. That's a big baseball
card. Like in baseball card world,
that's like almost, you know, so they,
they specifically targeted that
baseball card. Huh? Prop that.
Or they just targeted him because
they knew he was in Montreal. Wow.
Drop Cam people.
Everyone needs job fucking baseball card
thing is weird that a piece of paper
from the 1950s could be worth so much.
It's so strange to me because I
understand save you a big Willie Mays fan.
I understand that you'll have like some
youtube clips that you like to watch or
you know,
you watch a documentary on him or
something and it's amazing for you cause
you're a fan. But I can't imagine
giving a fuck about his baseball card.
I mean,
I really can't imagine.
I can't imagine buying a baseball
card for a guy who alive.
Forget about a guy who I get to
the beach ball. Here's true bro.
But the videos or the baseball history,
you fucking idiot.
Like you don't have to have
baseball cards anymore.
The baseball cards were only cool
when people didn't have movies. Okay.
That's a baseball card. Printers. Yeah,
they did. It was like hard to get one.
You couldn't just scan the image and make
your own baseball card. You asshole. No,
you don't understand a piece of history.
If I go over to someone's house and
they point to a comic book and go,
this was the original of Spiderman one
is just spreading written one of one,
it's worth $50,000 I'm like,
well you're retarded because if
you ever open that magazine up,
it looks like shit. Cause the car
to the drawings look like shit.
The artwork sucks. It's not that good.
Like you know you can get it online.
You know you can get online,
you can watch it on your iPad.
You fucking idiot get a second print like
well you have to have it in your hand.
It has to be old as fuck. Right. It's the,
it's a better version of it
and you can get it on your,
I think you can get it on your iPad.
I'm sure he can probably get it on your
iPhone and it doesn't smell like an
antique bookstore.
Grandmother's closet. A smell.
That's actually better than smell
like your grandma's closet. Oh look,
it's in that fucking plastic
back. Meanwhile, I do miss
my comic book collection.
I do too.
That's one of the things I sold when I
was poor that I do regret and I could
never get it back if I just hung in there.
If I was just a little bit more ambitious
early on and made enough money so I
didn't have to roll pennies for food,
I fucking didn't have to sell
that because I didn't make much.
I saved those comic books.
I sold them when I was 21 and I
saved them from the time I was.
I think I started when I was like seven
or eight maybe too made me sad. Dude.
Threw him though. Like you would know
it. Read them. No, no I wouldn't.
Why would you want them? I don't
know. I don't know. Me just pulling
out and like, that's like memories, like
I'll go back, oh, I forgot about new moon.
It's really a waste of time
pulled up on your iPad.
Yup, you're right. It's really kind
of a waste of time and a lot of ways.
You know what really made me
super happy, creepy. First of all,
this is how cool David
Cho is. Okay. David Show,
when he did the podcast the
first time, um, you know,
I'd heard about him from Bordain.
Bordain told me gotta have mom's catch
crazy and I said, I would love to.
I meet him on right away. I just, this
warmth, I'm like this, I love this guy.
Like Bing right away. I, come on,
let's talk. And he gave me, he,
we talked about like,
uh,
like horror comics and hard illustrations
and Werewolf's and stuff and he gave
me a series of the,
that I had,
I didn't have of these old school like
1950s and sixties and seventies comic
books from like that era
that they had printed,
they'd recreated and printed in book
four and hardback book form is amazing.
And he drew that picture that's
outside in the front. I'm like, who's,
who's that cool? Who does that for you?
Who gives you a gift and a piece of art,
you know, I mean David Cho is
the coolest motherfucker ever,
but the fact that this book was printed,
I love cars.
I love that I could go through this hard
back book and look at these comic books
that I used to.
I used to love those when I was a kid,
like a creepy and
ereader and all those uh,
black and white illustrated horror
comic books. They were awesome.
I couldn't wait for the new
ones to come out, man. They,
they were everything when I was a kid.
Those things were amazing.
So the fact that you can get
those today on your Ipad,
I don't know if he can get those,
but you know, you're not
getting the advertisements.
You're not getting like that.
The Spanish fly advertisements in
the comic books they used to have,
where are they? A X ray x Ray
classes. Cosby specials. Yeah.
You couldn't get anything. Yeah. You
could only get, you couldn't get the,
the knowledge that the thing
was actually from that time,
like that corvette that I have.
One thing I love about that car is it
that car that's a 1965 car of cars from
1965 you know,
it's been a bunch of stuff's been done
to it to make it like handled better.
But that's a 1965 is for car is
two years older than me is weird.
It's weird.
It's weird to have this time capsule
something and to think that this thing was
designed and implemented and created and
sold before you were even a thought in
your dad's Dick
that's been fucked in by other people
in the past. Ghost fuckers, man.
You don't 37 mini p 37
million people used.
Ashley Madison and I heard
about that and it got hacked.
They tried to advertise for the
podcast and I was like, Ooh,
I think you're on your own. I was like,
I don't think this is the way to go.
And what's interesting about the whole,
the whole thing is that people are
freaking out already. You know,
people that have used the site, so they're
having fake lists go out of like, uh,
like reddit had a fake list the other
day of supposedly that the list has been
released.
And so what,
which is a great idea because then you
don't really know which is the real list,
which is the fake list.
It just storing credit cards from
target or is it just information,
just information that you brought
that up because I watched it,
commander were on the plane the
other day and I tweeted about it.
It was fucking amazing.
And it was a documentary that everybody
that believes in like really wacky shit
about the Ufo world and you
know art bell type Shit. Yeah.
Mirage man. You got to watch
that. You have to watch that.
And it doesn't conclusively prove in
any way that you, fos aren't real,
but it's,
it sheds a lot of light on
a lot of ridiculous ideas
that people have about Ufo
is that they have accepted as fact and
documents that they point to as fact.
It's amazing. It's a good documentary
man. I watched it twice already.
I watched it.
And it may,
it literally made me watch it again so I
could get a better gist of exactly what
was going on in the documentary.
But it's about this guy named
Richard Doty and this guy,
but you Doty was a,
uh,
he was a dis information agent for the,
for the government.
So when someone would take a photo of
some experimental craft that they're
working on,
this guy would find out about it and he
would contact them from the government
and provide and tell them that he wanted
to see the photos and that because that
they were aware, he would introduce
them to some other information,
but on the grounds that they
keep their mouth shut about this.
And so he would tell them like that human
beings are engineered from monkeys and
aliens came down and we have the evidence
and they're the reason why we created
the transistor and all
this different crazy shit.
And he would talk about Roswell and the
airplanes that crashed and show them
fake pictures of autopsies and say,
I will show you this data.
But under two for two, there's going to
be two rules. One, you can't tell anyone.
And two,
you can't record any of this.
So he would give them this stuff
and show them and say, you,
we need you to fight against this
incoming invasion of aliens and whatever.
Just information he felt
like doing at the time.
Whatever wacky shit this dude felt like
making up. And it was totally into his,
his discretion.
So this guy would do this and then one
of the things he would do is go to these
Ufo conferences where they would repeat
the shit that he made up and he's in the
back room like this during the
video and he's in the back room,
this Ufo conference at the
Flamingo in Vegas like this.
And he's clapping while these people,
these poor fucks who have dedicated
their entire lives to proving they know.
Do you understand that?
They know they have been in contact with
an official United States government
agent who is told them there was an
imminent invasion and these people fucking
believe it. So they're traveling
all over the country. They live in,
in the backseat of their,
and they're,
they're basically these people that
are pushed to the brink of suicide that
believe without a doubt that they are in
contact with a fucking government agent.
And one of the guys winds up doing that
winds up. I think he killed himself.
I got to go, what the
fuck? I can't remember.
Cause he was a guy that was,
they were bringing him to um,
they were bringing them
to psychiatric clinics.
They thought he was completely losing
his mind and he was the guy fucking
African.
I fucking died.
He was a guy that was absolutely convinced
that the United States government was
providing him with real information and
that no one was aware of this thing that
he had to tell them about that we are
being monitored there. They're coming,
they're going to take us back. We are
androids like, oh, it's wacky shit.
This dude was telling him and this
guy would sit in the back of the room.
The guy who told them was just
the ultimate puppet master.
It's amazing man.
The Da.
The documentary is amazing because the
guy has a smirk on his face the entire
time he's talking about it and you
realize this crazy fucker just created the
like a giant percentage
of the whole UFO folklore.
It all came from this one crazy fucker
and this one organization and there's
another guy on it too as a younger guy.
Seems like he's got his shit together
and he's talking about, you know,
there's alien beings from,
you know,
thousand light years away or whatever
the fuck he's talking about it and he's
another admitted government agent
and he's talking about, I'm like,
well you're doing it now.
You're doing it now.
You're doing it now cause you must be
doing it now. If you're not doing it now.
You'd have some pictures and videos and
some stuff to show us like you sang that
there's,
how do you know that there's some,
you don't just say
there's a fucking planet.
I know because I have access to very
secretive government information that lets
me know you can't just
do that. No, you have to.
That's how the whole science thing works.
As far as it's been explained to me.
You have to exactly show, you have
to bring data. You have to have,
there's has to be something
before you say that.
Otherwise people aren't going to
listen to you. Well, who told you, oh,
that guy told you his name is
Richard Doty. Oh, that guy.
I'm going to show you a video about that
guy, that guy talking about what he did.
You goofy fuck. What's it called
again? It's called Mirage. Men Mirage,
man. It's, it's, it's amazing.
It's amazing. It's, it's,
it's really almost a psychological
documentary than it is a documentary about
Ufos.
Cause it's the thing that I,
I'm recognized in myself
when I had wacky beliefs.
I still have a bunch of wacky beliefs.
I'm not saying I'm immune to them,
but one of the things that I recognized
in myself and why I, you know,
believed in like, um, uh,
you remember those things that were a
raw, right. Remember those rods things.
Oh my God, I watched a
video. Any Pravo. He and I,
we that you know, the man that
remember that Alien Fish Bong I had,
I still have it. Um, but we,
we filled that alien fish bong up with
a God's creation and we watched this
stupid fucking VHS tape of an artifact.
The artifact is when bugs
fly really close to a camera,
their wings move so fast.
The video camera's Lens can't quite
capture it correctly. And Jamie,
you're a professional photographer.
He could explain what's
going on with that aperture.
F like the frames per second with the
video faster moving too fast to capture
the light.
So what it does in the images,
CV pull video up cause
it's glorious what it does.
And the image that I was
fucking convinced, okay,
I was convinced to the DNA.
I knew these things were around us.
We just couldn't perceive them and say
that's the lane. What was the other thing?
That lens flare one where like do you take
a picture and there's like, oh my God,
there's a ghost and these orbs,
orbs,
orbs.
But no one ever captured
until they figured out digital
cameras and he's still,
Eddie still believes that right orbit.
He's got some proof. He's gets improved.
That backs up his,
cause.
I remember Eddie was the one that
was really into the orbs. Eddie,
he loves everything.
Well like, like Eddie,
I didn't have the best childhood but mine,
I think it was better than his until I,
uh,
I want to believe in mystical bullshit,
magic things.
I think there's a big part of us.
I think the reason why
people like thinking about
bigfoot over killer whales is
only because we don't know for sure if
big foot existed at big foot definitely
existed. He's way closer to
us than a killer whale is.
Killer whales would be amazing
if they didn't exist. We,
if someone told you that there was some
intelligent life form that was like a
fish, but it was also, it was
also a, a mammal in some way.
This is those stupid things. The Sky,
they're calling it sky fish flying rods.
And it's just the,
um,
it's an artifact of these cameras
not being able to pick up on the bug
correctly. So as the bug moves across the
screen, it looks like an elongated rod.
What's really stupid about it,
and I didn't think about it at the time,
is that if it really was moving that fast,
like as you see it in this video,
you'd be able to see it like I see it.
Yeah. You know what I'm saying? I
mean, when they do it in high speed,
some of them you can see and when they
slow it down and they become these rods,
that's the only time where
they look like a Rod.
It's when it slowed down
and you speed it up.
It looks like a bug because it
is a fucking bug. God dammit.
Like you could almost
figured it out watching him,
but one dude got really nutty and
attached to the idea and produce these
documentaries about an artifact.
And then see,
look at that one flying
across the fucking,
this is a hole in the ground in Mexico.
And as these guys or sky
diving into this whole,
it's whole goes like a mile into the
ground. It's like an underground cave.
This dude filmed,
these people dive in into this hole
and these rods all around them.
But there's, if you put it on a high
speed camera camera that captures many,
many frames per second, like those red
cameras or any of those like digital, um,
prod cast quality cameras, then you
don't see it. You just see bugs.
So they figured it out on that show.
Monster Quest,
like they showed back to back footage.
They have two cameras over a firehouse, a,
um, a, a campfire,
and the two f the f
campfire attracted bugs.
So as the two cameras filmed at, one of
them was high speed, one of was standard.
The standard ones showed
all these fucking process.
The high speed one showed bugs.
So they're funny.
I fucking believed it, man. Dude, I
believe different months, I don't know,
it might've been a year. It might've been
a year and a half. You see the video,
that giant squid that the Russian
sailor's found like this ray Eric. Yeah.
But that's real. I know. I didn't know
they got that big dog get newsman.
No, they get absolutely enormous. Well,
here's a fascinating thing about the giant
squid is that until like a decade ago,
it was just a legend.
Like no one had any idea
that I don't think they'll be dick
and stuff was about right. Like, well,
not exactly, but it's about a
version of it. And matter of fact,
they found these fossil
remains, um, not remains,
but these fossils of imprints from a,
a dead being suction cups and they believe
it's evidence of something that would
have been referred to as the cracking.
She, the thing about the ocean, okay.
One of the things about these ocean
animals as far as it's been as it's been
explained to me, is that, uh,
the issue with trying to figure out
how long things have been around this,
first of all, it's too big
to explore. You're dealing
with this enormous, enormous,
enormous, enormous, see
several bodies of water,
but all of them are just way too big
for you to call him 100% of the water.
Then you've got to think about the fact
that all these beings look at this crazy
giant squid you sings are so big. Do
you see the one pull the one up? Ah,
that was taken by,
um,
I believe it was an Exxon oil rig and
it was a crab alien looking thing.
But my point being,
all these beings they're made at their
bodies are made out of flesh and their
bones are made out of like a Cartlidge
except for their skulls and their spines.
But all they have is like
this, these, you know these,
you've eaten fish bones before.
We've all gotten like fish. No,
we've all gotten like fish.
Like give it a salmon filet.
You get a rib in your mouth.
It's like a delicate little thing.
It's not like you're eating a bone.
I mean he'd call it a bone,
but it's like a different thing.
Everything at the bottom of the ocean
eats that shit out of that. That's gone.
So like to know how, yeah, that's
the thing. That's the a this is that.
Um, they didn't know. They have never seen
this thing before until 2007 they had,
they had even know this thing existed.
It's got like these bendy crab arms
that come off the back of a giant squid.
It's like a Dali painting,
right? [inaudible] it's so great.
Pull it to the beginning again
and just pause it when they,
when they zoom it out, you're like, what?
This is c'mon man. Pause that. Pause that.
If they found that flying space,
you'd be shitting your pants.
If they took the space shuttle up into
the atmosphere and they found that
hovering above the earth,
we would be shitting our fucking pants.
But the fact that this creepy thing,
this creepy bat wing looking spider
crab thing as living in the ocean,
we don't care. It's so
weird. Isn't this bizarre?
People go on the ocean, they go in
the ocean, the alien movie, right?
That's an alien movie.
100% things crazy,
but the point is that those things
are all there. They're all flesh.
It's almost all flesh except
for a beak like octopuses.
They're all flesh except for their beak.
So when you get down to it,
when they die, they just, they're
gone. They just get eaten by the,
it's really an efficient way.
You don't need bones.
Like we need bones in the water.
You need to be strong and pliable and
to be able to regenerate your limbs like
that seems to be a way
better idea than bones.
So octa can octopus regenerate
their limbs? Am I talking shit?
Can they have no idea? Hmm.
I need to find that out.
But the point is that we don't
know how big they used to get.
And so they found this fossil that
indicates that there's this huge fucking
suction cups. Enormous. So they think
it was this crazy fucking octopus.
They might've been a hundred feet
long. How octopus arms regenerate? Bam.
See with ease, pitch, trust in
your thoughts, not the weed.
We just submit it to your memory. Yeah,
they do grow back. Pull up that thing.
It could exist. They don't
know. Pull up that thing. Real
life cracking. Discovered.
Pull up the, uh, the images
that they've found of this, uh,
these enormous suction cups
that were fossil suction cups.
And they were thinking about there.
Okay. This cause they, they figured out,
I forget what year it was.
I don't think it was much earlier than
like 2000 where they found out that giant
squids were real. I matter of fact,
I'm being conservative I think,
but I think that um, up until then it was
just a mystery, like a myth, like the,
the idea of a giant squid. And then
once they found them they went, oh shit,
these are real. Okay.
So this is super recent.
Well this fossil, see that fossil up
there above the top, the top on there,
that's tentacles and
they're fucking enormous.
They're enormous.
Okay.
This shitty formatted
website and it gets too big.
Your Facebook stupid buttons
and Pinterest and Twitter.
I'll get in the way of the images,
the new discovery of fossils,
including the shell,
like fossil belief to belong to an ancient
octopus type creature, blah, blah, blah,
blah,
blah.
It supported the 2011 theory about
the existence of the cracking.
Can imagine if they did send one of
those fucking little James Cameron type,
individual billionaire dudes,
sub remains down there.
And he discovered a fucking 900 foot long
had just decided to eat that stupid
Tylenol capsule sized personal watercraft
that Mr. Cameron floats around in
85 and eight did he find anything?
Now he's the fucking guy who has gone
deeper than any human that's ever lived.
Do you understand this? That's how, what
a bad mother fucker James Cameron is.
He's the guy.
Yeah. Why isn't there a NASA
for our own earth? You know
like why don't we just go down there like
probably cheaper than like zillions of
dollars go in this space and we'll
probably figure out that like there's
something that's down there that's
like, okay, you guys want to know?
Like they could communicate with us and
tell us everything we want to know and
like, oh no. Some underwater door. See
that's, that's getting pushed it too far.
Here's my terrifying fear. Here's my
terrifying fear about all that shit.
My terrifying fear is that human beings
are the smartest things in the universe.
You think? Yeah, for sure. I'm,
no, no, definitely not for sure.
I don't even know for sure if I'm real.
I don't even know for sure if this isn't
some crazy dream or a video game where
all we're all planning. I'm
not sure. I'm not sure 100%,
but I'm not sure.
I just think that if you look at life,
Eh,
from, from an outside perspective, you
try to pay attention to what this is,
what this is for you. What is life did
define to me? What is life to you Brian?
Red Band, what's his
life to me? What is life?
Ah,
ah,
I think it's something that uh,
we're all programmed to do and it's
not gonna make sense until it's over,
but I think it's definitely
something that that's,
that's that word doing because
based off of something else,
like I saw something like I think
like I was born to, you know, like,
like you said earlier we
were talking about earlier,
like a cat finding the cat litter box.
If for some reason it knows,
I think every single person is born to do,
like they're already born in programmed
in a way to make it sound like something
we can relate to like a,
like a,
a phone or something like
that or an operating system.
We are programmed also to do,
to live a certain way,
to do a certain way to
think a certain way to uh,
have a certain talent or something that
you're drawn to. But I think we're all,
it's already been mapped out for the
most part too, to a point. Jamie,
do you agree with that? Uh, yeah,
to a certain extent. I mean,
I think you're drawn
places for sure. Um, but I,
I don't know that, I don't know, cause
I've had certain things pop up my,
my life where I've, like, I thought
I still, I'm going to do forever.
I'm playing sports forever,
you know?
But that isn't that just something
that's cool that comes into your life and
interests, maybe a hobby, I don't know.
Something that gives you like a new buzz.
Uh, yeah. I guess if I look
at it, the kind of all similar
though, creating stuff,
there's been, yeah, you're, you're more
drawn towards the arts and creating
where other people, you
know, John Towards numbers,
other people are drawn to dancing.
You know, I, I, I think it's,
well, I think I, when you die, it's
definitely going to be like, ah, yeah,
kind of thing. Double. That's what
psychedelics feel like, right?
When you have like a crazy breakthrough
psychedelic moment where, you know,
write the fucking universe fades on you.
[inaudible] one of the things
that you think is like, oh,
this is always been here. Yeah, I
remember this. Yeah. Yeah. This is here.
This is always here.
I think that's going to
happen again. And then, uh,
our soul's going to under the ocean.
We're all going to become
dolphins or something.
I just find it amazing how little we
know about shit that just happened.
I find it amazing that they're always
finding is these new pieces of information
that change things like this crack
him thing or about like this, uh,
they found some new evidence of
agriculture this 23,000 years old,
23,000 years old wheat growing,
and then that pushes civilization
back like some insane number.
I don't know what the original number was,
but I don't think it was less than
10 or more than 10,000 years ago.
So it went 13,000 years further,
at least.
At least where they found evidence of it,
you know,
who knows how much evidence there is of
shit. It's just gone. It doesn't exist.
How does that battery from Iran or Iraq?
That's so cool. Like you're saying. Yeah.
Do you think there's anything in
the future that's controlling us
now? Anything? Right.
What I was saying earlier is
that I think that my fear is,
and it's not really a fear because
I think we're pretty awesome. I'm a,
I'm an unabashed,
um,
enthusiast of human beings. I think
human beings are pretty fucking cool.
I think for sure there's some ones that
are a mess and those ones that are a
mass they can get,
they can get into some positions where
they can cause trouble for everybody else.
And part of it's our fault because we
allowed them to have the responsibility of
managing certain areas.
Like if you look at the human race as a
whole and then you look at some insane
pollution like you go to, you ever been
to Detroit? Oh yeah. Nice there this year.
Did you go to the river
area? Yeah, I do. Dude, it's
depressing is it? Oh my God, we,
we filmed there for that Psi Phi show
that I did and when while me and my friend
Todd, we're driving around this
river, we were like, fuck dude,
this is awful like that, that God damn
river has been poisoned, you know?
And everybody kind of knows that it's
one of the most polluted areas in the
world. I mean, collectively,
I think we all know that,
right? As a, as a, as a race,
but we don't feel, we're not responsible.
We didn't do it. I didn't do it.
You didn't do it. So
somebody did it. Well,
what percentage of the people that
did it did it at a 350 million people?
What percentage of that population
polluted the Detroit river? It's small.
It's super small, but a small
percentage can start a nuclear war.
A small percentage can cause the
genocide is small. It's small.
But if you let them get away with it,
they can do some fucked up shit.
It's small. But I think
overall, and this is,
and I understand people that
say, oh, people suck. I get it.
I know what you're trying to say.
I know you're trying to say we can
definitely suck in comparison to the
potential that we show as well.
But here's the thing about the
people that tell me that people suck.
They usually don't suck. I
like them like, like they say,
people suck, man. People fucking suck.
I fucking hate people. And then I go,
but I like you and you're a person.
I like you.
And you're telling me that people
suck. Like you're nice, you're nice.
And I'm nice. So how are people, how
do people suck? How is that possible?
Some people suck, some people. Oh, okay.
So that's what percentage is that?
Could you imagine if like food,
if like one 1000000th of a percent of
food would give you fucking ridiculous
diarrhea, but you were
like, fuck food man foods,
bullshit food causes diarrhea.
Food Causes Cholera and be like, but
no, no, no, no. Most food nourishes you.
Most food takes care of you without most
food. You had died dude, foods bullshit,
bro. You know in Bangladesh, four year old
boy died from bad food and you're like,
well, what about the 7 billion people
that ate food and that they stayed alive?
That's to me the same sort of philosophy.
When people say that people suck.
I don't think people suck. I think
people can suck. I think I've sucked.
I think you suck. You suck all
the time. God dammit. Jamie. Hey,
these mean, I mean this what I mean
like as a potential, like as a,
as a potential.
I think the human race is insane.
I think it's the most amazing thing ever.
We might be the tip of the spear.
We might be.
It might be that it takes some weird
collection of carbon based life and a,
a constant environment and biological
entities that need the stun to stay warm.
It takes a lot of fucking weird shit to
create a person. They navigate Siberia.
Come across the Bering Strait,
make it in America,
make fucking edges with stones and
attached to the mystics and shoot him with
bows and arrows at Buffalo. I mean,
you're, you're dealing with a mad,
creative little weird animal.
It's not that easy to get to that point.
Why not just stay a squid?
Why not?
Squids had been squids
for 250 million years.
Why not just stay a stupid
fucking hammerhead shark?
Why not stay a fish that needs a dog
to go up to it and splash water on it
because it doesn't have legs like an
asshole. Just walk away. You fucked.
They can't, they can't walk away
and you can't breathe underwater.
Why does it create a human being?
It might be a blip in the system.
It might be the chimps are as good as it
gets anywhere and that all of a sudden
some weird thing happen and we came
along and we're the fucking top of the
intelligent ladder, but we
suck. We don't always suck, but
we suck on some occasions. On a lot
of occasions on memorable, memorable,
measurable occasions we suck.
You know,
we're a species that'll drop bombs on
countries indiscriminately to prove a
point like we did in World War One
and two. They, I mean worldwide. Sure.
Whether they ended the war by dropping
nuclear bombs just on a whole city boom.
That sucks, right? Everybody would
say, that sucks. We don't all suck.
We don't all suck.
I really think that we're in in the the
very end of a strange process on this
planet. I don't think we're more than a
decade away from being something that's
completely different than we are now.
I really think that
it's falling apart fast, faster,
and faster. Also, in a weird way,
man, weird. Our heroes are
now, you know bill Cosby,
that cover of New York magazine where it
has all the victims that's all lined up.
It's,
would you say five years ago you said
that bill Cosby was all this was going to
happen. You're like, you're
crazy. Shut the fuck up. No,
I would've never believed it. And
you know what? Here's the sad thing,
and this is on me.
I think probably five years ago,
I'd probably heard something crazy that
he did. Really? I don't, I don't remember.
I don't remember.
It was five years ago or,
but there was a trial that it was
in the news 10 years ago apparently.
And that was the one that he settled out
of court that they took the deposition
from and they used it in
this, uh, this new thing.
It's a sad as fuck, man. It's
sad as fuck it says, fuck that.
A person has been doing
that their whole life.
Trying to find a look at all the girls
that are on that. They want to look at it.
Man,
I don't want to see the navy had to type,
it doesn't really look like it just,
it's sad dude.
It's waste solder for them than it is
for him for sure. But it's still sad.
It's sad all around. It's fucked
up. It's wrong. It's just wrong.
We all know it's wrong. There's no one
defending that. You can't defend that.
You know? And what's
really interesting, man,
I've been talking about this on stage
about the animal house scene with the
devil and the angel. I remember
when the devil is like, fuck her.
Fuck her brains out soccer debts ever.
That you could never do that today.
You could never do that today.
You can never have a scene in
a comedy where a little tiny,
cute little miniature devil
was telling you a rape. Right?
They're written. There's that
other one though. Uh, what's,
uh, happening? Hot stuff.
Uh, what's that movie where she was passed
out and uh, what's that movie called?
Do you remember? Jamie?
Hmm. Uh, there was a lot,
there's a lot of movies that have weird
drunk rape type scenes or where they're
passed out or like feeling
their tits up like hot dog.
I probably has a few and meatballs and
all those other eighties perv movies that
involve Porky's Porky's
hotdog skiing, no hot dogs.
Porky's on skis is a real movie.
There was a gang of those movies. Maybe
this was another one, right? Who did,
I totally forgot about those movies.
I forgot about Porky's until right
now until you just brought that up.
I probably haven't
thought about Porky's in 10 years.
10 solid shower scene where
they're looking through
the shower and just Porky's
was hot. You should never do that today.
That was total creeper rapist shit.
That's what's, well that's pretty much
what the Seth Rogen movies are now.
You know, that's their version of
like the, the uh, super bads. Yeah.
They can get away with some stuff.
They can get away with some
stuff as far as like, um, like,
like the drawing of the Dicks I remember
so close to home.
It's so ridiculous.
They can get away with some stuff that
they could have never gotten away with
back then. But back then they could
get away with the insensitive stuff.
Like you could never have drawing
dicks and animal house movie.
We would show the guy drawing all the
dicks. People weren't ready for that.
Now that is like,
to me in a strange way,
some sort of evidence of evolution
that's like imprinted in our media.
Like that seems to me to be the biggest
evidence that human beings are moving
towards something better than we are now.
Which is one of the reasons why I think
that like why there's so much criticism
and so much like there's so much
anger and people mad at people today,
like we're even when we were talking
about like people mad at celebrities and
people mad at Tmz for
following celebrities and
people mad at celebrity shows.
Like there's,
I think there's got to be at
least somewhere in that anger,
ms misguided as it may be,
this desire for all of us to do better.
And I think it sort of manifests itself
in some kind of a weird dystopia.
It's weird, a vibration of anger
that runs through our culture, but,
but it's,
it's not like an unsurmountable problem.
And I think people look at it like
it's an unsurmountable problem.
But I think like human
beings, like overall, I think,
like I say the word light
too much about that. I like,
don't even like what the
fuck I'm like talking about,
I think human beings overall
are getting way better.
I think we're getting way better.
So when something like the whole coke and
things or something like that happens,
people get super bummed out
because like fuck not hulk Hogan.
Not Whole Cogan Shit like that.
Dude.
Why does he believe silly shit like live?
She does believe silly shit.
Maybe he doesn't believe it anymore.
What am I go Jackson
things totally different.
Cause it's not just a thought.
It's an action allegedly. Right.
Well it's still theory. It's
awesome to the point of, you know,
we grew up Michael Jackson.
How was the king now? He,
that was the coolest person ever. And
watch him deteriorate over the last years.
And then all the, I, you know, with all
this Cosby shit and all the kids stuff,
if Michael Jackson was still alive,
he would be the next Cosby.
We would find out that all
these kids, like even, you know,
Corey Haim would come out and say, Oh
yeah, he fucked me good. And you know,
Shit like that, right?
Damn. Don't you think so?
I don't know.
I mean
if they could take down cause speed,
they can definitely get to
Michael could be or it could be.
He's still friends with all those kids.
I still get it. Again, still tagging it.
That's so wrong. He lets them
in a Neverland, but like, uh,
I don't remember who said this first.
It does definitely isn't my idea.
I just can't remember who said it.
Someone was saying that like
all the, all, all the evidence was there.
Like what kind of a grown ass man has a
goddamn amusement park at his house and
100% they were just saying like,
this is like,
this is the most ridiculous thing ever.
That this guy is accused of pedophilia.
Any has an amusement park
for children in his house.
And he talks like a child.
Like, wait, what? No, no,
he's fine. You don't leave your kids
with them. He'll be fine. It's just,
it's a crazy,
insane aberration that somehow or another,
a child who grows up with this dominant
father in this family of musicians and
they're all singing and dancing
and travel in the country.
And he's loved by everybody from
the time he was a little kid. Dude,
if you've watched the Jackson five,
think about this.
Think about if you were Tito or Jermaine
or any of these other people that were
Jacksons. Think about who they are. Okay.
These are grown ass men and and
older children of this supernova.
Your, your parents had a bunch of
kids and they had one Super Nova.
They had Janet Jackson, they
had Tito, they had Jermaine,
they had a Latoya that all these
Jacksons and then they had Michael this
nucleus,
this fucking just white hot thing.
So much that everybody goes,
he's got a son,
he's gonna say he's going to dance
and he does it on TV and he hits it
perfectly.
He hits a perfectly t for anybody to
ever try to figure out what it would like
to be would it would be
like to be Michael Jackson.
You've got to watch Michael Jackson when
he was on TV when he was a little kid,
but it pull,
pull some of that up Jamie,
because I think we could all like,
we can all agree. Let's just agree on some
stuff before we talk about this. Okay?
Pedophilia is one of the worst things you
could ever do. For sure. We all agree,
right?
We all agree that anybody that harms a
child is a terrible fucking person and we
don't want that in our
world. We all agree, right?
But let's look at this, this
life. Let's look at his life.
Let's try to look at it outside of that
judgment, which we all agree on and say,
this is these, this life, this
choice, this, this situation.
A scenario that he was
born into is not his idea.
It is not his idea to be this little
tiny person who is exposed to millions of
people on television.
It's not
his idea. And so you're looking at
right now, play this man. What does this
look it? Look how good he is
to look at this. Turn this up.
Totally adorable. Oh
my God. He was amazing.
Look at his brother's in the background.
How much they hate life.
You got a bunch of dudes who
are already getting laid.
One of them doesn't do anything but
dance is seems the Middle Guy. Yeah,
and then there's another little guy
who's like, Michael, do it now. I'm next
round. Diamonds are, first of all,
they're excellent musicians. Listen to
this song. Crack this shit up, Jamie.
God Damn,
this is good.
The sudden having music play this out
afterwards. It's just when
he's drunk. No Grammar,
no drum.
Jamie's right
Jamie. Just spended my
fucking love for this song.
It's about the bill of goods
though. Mass. We'll look at him.
Look at him. Go Man. He's got
a leather vest on with tassels.
Like he's the outlaw Josey Wales.
Oh my God. This is incredible. Which
ones? Tito, Tito guy. I don't know.
I don't know who anybody is. I
know Michael Jackson is, I'm the,
I'm a casual fan and I feel
bad for that right now.
I
is this great.
God Damn,
this is good.
I got news for you,
man.
If this shit was on Conan O'brien
tomorrow and these guys below up,
they will blow up like Mount Saint Helens.
They would blow up. This
is just good. This is a,
an entertaining,
tight performance
of a Badass band. And they could dress
the same way. They're dress right now.
They could dress the exact same way,
do this exact same show that's coming.
We're all gonna have our virtual hologram.
We get to go see them again,
but in Hologram form at a place. I
know, but I mean that place that,
that whole that in Chicago,
man, that looked real like
they have a trunk. You Go.
No, no. My friend produced it
was one of the producers of it.
And then this is the one that chief Keef
that got this got shut down, right? Yeah,
the mayor. Chef key for
chief. Good. Thank you.
I get a a squash butternut suit.
I get really,
I'm very white. I get so
confused. I'm so sorry.
So he got shut down. He was doing,
they did his hologram. Yeah.
And it got shut down by the police,
by the mayor.
The mayor pretty much just came
on and stepped in and said, hey,
I don't like this guy because
he had some warrants in Chicago.
This is in Chicago, knows happening,
Indiana. They had to move it to Indiana,
but they,
they pretty much told him to just pull
the plug on it after the first song.
So the first song, first song
hall, Graham, chief Keef came out,
everything was going fine.
That mayor then told him to turn off
all the electricity there and pulled it,
which is, you know, freedom
of speech thing for one. Uh,
and there's also a lot
of weird laws about,
cause this was broadcast live and the
mayor just came in and was like, Eh,
I don't like this guy. And like pulled
it a live performance just because, uh,
you know,
has there been any sort of an examination
of what the mayors allowed to do? Yeah.
What he's legally allowed to do? I
don't know, but it seems like, I mean,
when I first heard about, I immediately
was like, this does not seem legal.
You know, what if this was, you
know, the end on top of this,
this was to raise money
for, uh, you know, uh,
the people that were
affected by that huge, uh,
all these people got shot in Chicago
recently, like a ton of people.
And ever a child that, and this was
to raise money for them. And uh,
listen to that. Hold on a
second. [inaudible] I know
nothing about chief Keef,
Mayor Mcdermott, he's
only 46. The mayor said,
all I'd heard is that he has a lot of
songs about gangs and shooting people at
history.
That's anti-cop pro gang and pro drug use.
He's been basically outlawed in Chicago.
We're not going to let you circumvent
mayor Emanuel by going next door.
The Chicago Mayor's office
did not immediately respond
to a request for comment.
Isn't that hilarious? So he's a quote
from that. They didn't comment who?
The mayor, if the mayor is uh, uh,
Indiana mayor where this manual?
Chicago mayor. Oh, okay. Different Dude.
Okay. So the Indiana mayor is
only 46, but the Chicago mayor,
so the Chicago mayor contacted
the Indiana mayor and said, Hey,
shut that shit down. Shut it down. Which
could know they could just do that.
It's a Hologram. And Hey guys,
let's, let's talk about ice cube.
Let's talk about jokster dre.
Let's talk about any of these
other fucking people that
did the exact same thing.
Nwa All talked about killing cops,
shooting cops,
fuck the police and all that stuff,
and you guys are celebrating.
Why don't you pull all the beats
headphones out of all the stores,
mayor of Indiana for saying,
you know,
all this shit you've said in your past
music that now we're all going to see in
the new Nwa movie and it's uh, we're all
going to be singing it again. So yeah,
right at a time,
right now having Nwa the movie
come out is so strong and powerful,
but this guy trying to raise some
money, uh, not, not even him,
a whole gram version of him trying to
raise money and they shut it down after
the first song. I just don't
think, if no one's doing a crime,
you should be to say that
saying words,
unless you likes organizing
some sort of attack on someone.
But the idea that you're saying words
mean,
what does every movie that we
go to see? I just, what is,
what does every gangster movie,
Oh,
should we stop the creation of
gangster movies? Bunny hat, fake bugs.
Bunny had dynamite.
Tons of explosions.
We tried to kill a lot of
violence in that Wiley,
coyote and bugs bunny.
But I'm sure bugs bunny was involved
in an explosion or two. Yeah. Yeah.
Every fucking movie we love has
destruction, right? Everybody says that.
Murder's bad. Everybody says that. But
how many fucking movies of murder in it?
Jesus Christ. Right? What percentage of
them? Let's just Gambino's murder in it.
We don't get, we don't know. Okay. This
is a beautiful subject right here. Don't,
don't even look at Jamie.
I want you to guess what percentage
of movies have murdering them?
Guest Jamie.
First murder.
Oh Wow. All movies. That's
a big thing. So, I dunno.
40% 40% American,
some sort of murder.
Brian, what do you think?
Well, I was going to go higher,
but since he went so lower,
lower, uh, all movies,
I'd probably say murder or
violence, right? Just murder. Uh,
I'd probably say 32%.
32%. All right. Well, let's find out.
Jamie, why don't you Google that?
I'm trying to figure it out.
It's too difficult.
It's too difficult for me to do while
I'm doing the show still because you're
just too many statistics
you'd have to go through.
There's like a lot of it is surveys found
82% of Americans believe that movies
have too much violence. Okay.
That's not what I asked for.
You fuck different people.
How many times they've died in movies?
If I had to guess, I'd say
10%. Wow. What did you say?
32% to would you say genuine?
40. 40. I think I said 10,
right? 10. I don't think, uh,
I think in real life,
if 10% of people who got murdered,
you'd be fucking terrified. There'll
be a horrible world to live in. I mean,
that's like Gingiss Khan days.
10% of the people die, right?
You have a short lifespan.
If he's like short cycles of human beings,
just keep having babies and keep dying
off quick and known, figured out anything.
What percentage do you think, Jamie? I
didn't hear all the questions. Sorry. No,
what percent.
I mean you're doing it right.
We found out that I actually just found
the same thing. You just found, oh,
we'll figure it out. But
I think that, uh, it's,
I think the numbers thing is like
very deceptive. They weighed a lot,
a lot of deceptive numbers.
How many deceptive numbers of people
that are fucking up the world?
What are the deceptive numbers
of a dummies out there?
I don't think there's nearly as many
as everybody thinks hers. You know,
I think a lot of the dummies are
unhappy being dummies and we'll,
we'll keep them dummies forever.
We'll never allow them to not be
dummies anymore. You know, they get
trapped and will dummy
world some dummy friends.
I, I also, you know, I saw the
house of blues the other day.
They had this free concert on sunset
and they originally went to the Roxy and
there were like, uh, is this
guy named justice? What's his
name? Oh, future a future.
That shouldn't be your name, sir. You
can't have that as a name. Just like,
I can't have math as a name.
You can't call yourself future.
That's just ridiculous.
That's like a known word
that's like I'm tripod.
So using the hold will be channel
slept dog. I'm tripod, tripod.
I like that tripod. It's implied you
have a large penis, but he shut down.
He shut down the row. They, they
had a free show at the Roxy.
So many people showed up like
a thousand people or something.
Like they had to shut down
sunset boulevard at the Roxy.
So then they moved it to the House
of Blues and the same shit happened.
Like it was like I had to
go on stage and the whole,
there was swat team guys with guns
on the side of the comedy store.
There was helicopters and then somebody,
something happened where people
were like spraying like uh,
extinguishers or smoke bombs and he had
to shut the whole thing down. But for,
for a second there,
it was amazing how fast that could have
turned into a riot situation and stuff
like that. So when the,
this concert was shut down,
you would think that they were trying
to control a riot of some kind,
or what would be the reason
other than taking money out of a,
uh, uh, event that was for
a toddler that died, uh,
due to violence, do you think that would
be a place that would have violence?
Is that a benefit show for a toddler?
Well,
because of violence,
here's the thing.
It shouldn't be the mayor's arbitrary
decision to decide to shut down a show
like that.
Especially to do it while you got to
think he's probably grand standing, right?
You know,
that's what he's doing.
He's making a big stand and he's
going to stop gang violence.
And we all agree that's,
it's better to have less violence in
the world's better to have less fun.
But you can't just decide in the middle
of a show to shut it down. That's stupid.
And that's not thinking about the future
because you're going to have a whole,
how many people are at a show, like
10,000 fucking people or something crazy.
It's a huge festival or some kind
of festival. Right? So let's,
let's just say it's 10,000 people.
How many people were there to see them?
They're all there to see him.
You shut it down. They're mad.
So now you've got a group of people that
aren't just going to get entertained.
They're mad if criminals are
criminals all the fucking time,
24 hours a day, seven days a week,
what kind of a world would it be?
Would be crazy. It would be like
criminals would be like zombies.
They would just be just running
around, grabbing things. They're not.
So they gotta be in a situation where
crime could erupt. Most of the time,
criminals aren't committing crimes.
Even the most hardened criminals
out of their waking day.
What percentage is actually
dedicated to crime?
It's probably pretty fucking small,
right?
But now if you set them up in
this situation where you take away
their money and you sh you stopped their
show and you stop it because you don't
like what this person is saying on stage
and now they're in a position where
they feel wronged,
they feel like you owe them.
You have to you, you've created
a feeling of that. Yeah.
You've created a feeling of anger
and parked. I had to call off work,
I had to do this.
I like now you've just created a
mob of people against the system.
The good man.
Yeah,
it's not smart and there's a lot of cool
videos of that night where you know the
show was going on,
everything was going great and you just
see in the background for like a one 80
just these lights coming closer and closer
of all the cop cars just coming from
the distance because Indiana is flat is
fuck. So you can see just not so true.
I didn't even think of, yeah, it's a,
that's a weird thing about getting
away with crime in Indiana.
You fucking look around. All you
need is like a, yeah, a tower.
Like you've got about 30 seconds that
covered about six miles away getting the
fucking car. Let's do this
drive. Slow drive sob. I saw.
It's really great though.
Like these apps like periscope and things
like that that are really using it as
for the news and for kind of
like crime checking, you know,
like I got a video of you. What do you
think about these drones? Like the,
the fact that they're able
to use, when I was, um, uh,
up in Canada a couple months ago,
it was one of those guys who's a friend
of a friend had a drone and it was
hooked up to his iPhone and I was
like, this is crazy. What is this?
He's showing me video from his iPhone on
his iPhone of this fucking robot that's
just flying around. I'm
like, that is insane.
I can't believe you can actually do
this. Have you heard of Lilly? No,
I can't wait. It comes out very soon.
Lily, is this like, it's like the,
it looks like it's going to be the,
like the first iPhone of drones.
Like it's going to be one of the ones,
it's like your own personal drone check.
Check this video. It's pretty
sweet. All this shit it can do well,
here's a commercial. So I think,
I don't know, maybe Jamie,
you can pull it up.
Probably be better. Uh,
so what is the idea that it's a better
drone? It's, it's just like here you're,
you're holding it.
You can just throw it in the air
and it turns on automatically.
You could have it either fall you at
directly behind you side, sideways.
And it's adorable looking at turn
up the volume. It's got eyes.
She looks kind of like a blue little,
see how he just threw it up and
then I followed, yeah, look,
come on.
And so it's going to track your,
this is just showing if you were
going to be a snowboarder and my God,
we have HD, we have robot falcons. Yeah.
This is a robot Falcon Falcon that follows
you around and he comes to you and it
comes shipped to the fuzzy landing,
20 minute flight time.
All my throat over a bridge.
God,
this is the craziest Shit
I've ever seen in my life.
Uh Oh my God. It's just walk
like grand theft auto style.
Just walk behind you.
Oh my God.
One of the coolest things is going
to Kayak. You can just go as fast.
How fast can it go? It goes, I don't
know what, how fast they usually go,
but it's pretty much if, oh, you
were tracking Weist. Oh my God.
Oh my God. Look at that. You wear a
tracking device around your wrists. Yeah,
dude,
we're live and love future could either
go in front of you and lead or follow.
Oh my God.
And we're talking 60 frames
a second full HD. Oh,
fixing your backpack. Oh
my God. This is crazy.
Grandma could use it to
make sure follows her.
Oh my God,
Dude.
How long before people give up their
bodies for that just blew my head to the
top of that thing.
You know,
there's gonna come a point in time where
human beings have like a biological
meeting and we decided now that
we have genetic engineering,
should we decide to continue with
shape? Should we decide to continue
with this shape? What is love?
What is beauty in the eye of the beholder?
Could we all be better
off if we were flying?
Jellyfish are nice.
They come up with this proposition
to be able to replace a,
with a simple prescription,
uh,
any feelings of love or sex or
affection that people need or want.
It's all satiated.
You,
you never have to worry about reclaiming
that again and that the most harmonious
shape for the universe,
the most harmonious shaped
to coexist forever with a,
an infinite lifespan is flying jellyfish.
How long before we'd all be
flying jellyfish, seven years,
the way that thing just flew.
I want it to be that thing.
I know it's good to just fight
through it off a bridge, right?
Wish someone gets throw,
just throw you off a bridge and you
just won't shred this. And this is,
imagine that technology in 20 years
where that thing's falling around all day
long, all night long. I imagine
that in the shape of Dicks,
imagine what's the figure out that the
shape of a dick is really not perfect.
You know,
just like there's other shit that's wrong
with people like the fact that so easy
to knock us out. Yeah, that's a big
flaw. Punch somebody in the chin,
they go unconscious is a stupid flaw.
What if they realized like
dicks are good but have a seat.
I'm going to show you the new,
we're going to show you the next level,
the next level, some sort of new thing,
and it gets inside you and just expands,
expands like a fist,
but soon a few little dicks all around
a tube like this or the the main dick
tube and it's spreads out like corn,
you know,
and it's all a little Dick's inside.
Imagine if your Dick was, uh, this might
be the dumbest thing I've ever said.
Imagine if your deck was like an ear
of corn and each one of those little
kernels was another
dick. And once your Dick got in
there and we'd, Dick was hard,
you dick got in there, then
all those little dicks would
pop out and move it all.
Like they would all play music inside
the girl's vagina, downtown, downtown,
downtown tome.
And that would be the thing.
Like the girls could come the hardest.
You've made the best music
inside their vagina. Oh, Joe.
That's what I'm saying.
Right? Good. Listen.
That's a very important point.
We just assuming that the Dick shape
that we have currently is the best,
but if you had the dick shape we had
currently and the ability to make music
with your deck, right? Yeah. Jamie. Jamie,
don't look at me like what kind of
music you, donk, Donk, donk, downtown,
some Beethoven Shit.
Piano or a violin or mostly like drums.
I guess it depends on what you're
trying to accomplish. Yeah.
I'm more of like a you a
Bongo player or a bass drum.
I can see Jamie playing upon.
Guys had a party, play a gym day.
Uh, if you were a sex act, would you be
V if you are a sex act and
also a musical instrument,
what is sex act?
And I was asking him who's the bongos
or if he was the bass drum would
definitely be the band. Would
you be the trumpet? Yeah. Oh,
would you be the trombone trumpet?
It's a phone.
Every man wants,
let's
be the electric guitar,
right? Yeah. Good. All right.
What's the plate first? If you had a
big buck, the best sound, best sound,
the best sound.
And all of music to me,
I think like the sound that makes me
go the most gold fuck is like awesome
guitar. Like someone who
really nails it like that.
I'm the solo in um,
uh,
Leonard skittered the solo
and Freebird you know,
you know that solo when they get there
there's like a two and a half minute long
solo or something like that.
My personal opinion,
I think it's the greatest
solo and all of music.
guitar solo ever. I,
I listened to that fucking thing like once
a month it's like, like a little like,
uh, like an equinox or something like
that or a a full moon once a month.
I have to hear that guitar solo cause
it's so good. It's just this is,
I don't think I've ever
thought that way about drums.
He's never one time that I had to listen
to a drum solo over and over and over
again. It doesn't, it's not
that I don't appreciate drums.
I love drums and if it wasn't
for the drums, the whole
song wouldn't be the same.
Like no song will be the same.
But if I had to pick like one sound,
like what's the one sound that I enjoy
most for whatever reason is to the guitar
and I don't,
I don't think it's the electric guitar
or the Acoustic Guitar because some of my
favorite guitar moments,
it'd been like people we've had in the
studio like Everlast Everlast playing
guitar or like a Ben and Suzanne
from honey, honey playing guitar,
like in studio or Banjo. There's something
about someone touching something,
their fingers,
whether it's a banjo or
whether it's a guitar.
I know you're creating with your fingers
and it's got this crazy metal sound is
wire in this fucking echoey sound
and that's my favorite sound.
I've, I've come to that conclusion. Those
are my, that's my favorite musical sound.
I like drums alive there. There's a
few songs like you're right though.
For the most part it's guitar,
but there's a few drum solos that,
I mean piggy by nine inch nails.
Back in the day,
Chris Farina used to have one of my
favorite. This guy's plan a guitar,
dropped his iPhone inside his
guitar and put the camera out.
And you're seeing like each of the wave
forms on each string that he's playing
and like it's a visual visit.
Camera can't keep up with the vibrations.
Correct lists. I do not believe
this at all. No, that's,
that's what it looks like.
No,
but this has been reading done.
This is not try it with your cameraman
attains an iPhone four it's a shitty
camera. So I think it's a similar to
what we were talking about with the rods.
It's just an artifact where the lens
of the camera can't keep up with it.
But it has this con, this changing
image at the front of it like that.
When you look at it with your eyes,
you can see if I'm doing this when I get
home. Yeah, you got to do this. Please do.
Please do. Ah, alright.
He swiped your knee.
If there's one thing that I wish that I
did that I don't really wish that I did,
but I, I think it would be cool to know
you can still do it. It's not that hard.
Nope. Nope. Time you learn how to not
interested with Bose real quick. Nope.
You could learn to [inaudible]
pool game needs work.
I'm trying to write jokes.
I want to be social only hang out with
my family and play those songs. You know,
you already said here at Aera sang songs.
He jumped bears on my songs to be,
especially if I get drunk for
a Roto and stuck with them. Uh,
but if he did kid songs, how cool
would that be? Like how many do like,
oh we'll do this down. Oh yeah,
I want to do that with my kids.
They always gravitate towards
the same ridiculous stuff.
It always becomes about like buttholes
anuses cause they know it's hilarious.
Kids figured out early.
You don't even have to try to tell them
to say penis and butthole is hilarious
and they just go to it and
then when you laugh they go,
oh I figured out what's funny.
Little cute people saying ridiculous shit.
It is adorable. I think I knew it
but I wasn't allowed to say it.
If I were to say it, I would,
would've gotten a ton of trouble.
Isn't it weird though that we try to
prevent kids from San Ridiculous Shit like
penis and butthole like that is
your butt hole. This is a penis.
Like what are we doing?
We're gonna have to raise robots.
Do you let your kids cuss like, dude,
no. This is what I tell kids and I cuss.
Very rarely. I swear to God
because very rarely around my kids,
but I do occasionally slips
out and my wife goes, you know,
you know like you should probably
shouldn't say that around the kids. I go,
I guess you're right.
But all my favorite people swear like,
why do we have to wait
until they're old enough?
They swear because we're worried about
how they're going to appear to other
people. We'll look if everybody
talked away, the three of us talk.
Is that a bad thing? If kids talk
like that, is that a bad thing?
And what are we doing? We're not
mean. We're not. We're, we're,
we're not cussing about ridiculous shit.
You know,
you drive outside in, your
tire's flat, you go, fuck,
is that so bad?
I feel like kids know,
they just know.
They learn quick who you don't say it
in front of like you don't say anything.
They do,
they they it slips out.
It's a part of your vernacular.
If you live 30 years of your life and
then you have a kid 30 years of saying
fuck. Most of us have said
Fox since we figured it out.
As soon as you realize
what an impact fuck has,
well you'll actually like
seven or something like
that so and says fuck around
your kit. Get children just being
nice. The children are right here.
As soon as you realize that this
is like some Voodoo word, right,
you start using it.
I just think that the most important thing
is like it's not language,
it's intent.
Like what are you trying to
project by what you're saying?
Cause all we're saying when when we
get upset about language and were being
ridiculous about it.
When you're saying that there's no way a
person should ever be able to say these
noises with their mouth,
what are those noises to you?
What are those noises to you
and what are those noises to me?
Because what it really
is about is about intent.
And as soon as you pretend
that it's not about intent,
then you create this weird world
of like switches. It's on and off.
It's yes and no. And that's not, that's
not how people operate. You know,
people are weird. They're fucking
pliable. You know, people are strange.
Jamie has trained,
you see this drone shooting a gun.
That's what we have to look forward
to. I saw that too. That's real.
I wanted to ask you, it looks fake
as fuck, but why wouldn't it be rail?
It's one of those things,
you know,
why wouldn't it be really get
something to go backwards and forwards.
What you can't get it to pull a switch.
Oh my God.
And if you had a cross
hairs on it somehow.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
So this guy has a gun
that's flying around us.
The same guy, same guy, made this video
there showing yet. Remember that guy? Oh,
the guy that showed him being a taf or
recording video from a drone over a beach.
Yeah. Well, I don't believe
that. Is it the same guy? No,
I think this is all bullshit.
Why do you think it's bullshit?
I think that might be
real and I think I know.
I just don't think they're connected.
If that's connected.
That's crazy because so what's the
deal with drones? Anybody can have one.
You can do whatever you right. There's
no laws. You can't put a gun on. One.
Made some real weird laws at fas.
Had to make some regulations on where
you can and can't fly him and whatnot and
how high they can can't do in
a rover police departments.
You can't do it over planned parenthoods.
Is this like the fucking Trojan horse?
Is the drone the Trojan horse? Look, it
was created by the government for military
reasons and now they are selling it
where we can keep it in our book bagging.
Mom and dad can have their own drone
falling around the whole entire time.
In 10 years we'll all have a German,
they follows us around and records as
an HD 60 frames a second. Everyday we,
they found a way to put a drone in her
hand with periscope and all these other
things.
They're going to have best babysitting
skills ever in our government.
What about this?
What about the craziest idea of all time?
What about they figure out a way to
have cameras and we're recording devices
that are so small that they're literally
invisible and they put them everywhere
and they work as a matrix.
So as you're walking down a hall,
this thing can recapture the images that
it sees in front of it and record it
all in real time and broadcast
it to anybody. Anyone, anywhere.
That's the future. There
flies. Well that's,
that's the future man. It's not
just flies. I think it's molecules.
I think the cameras
become a part of the air.
I think the idea of having wireless
Internet to a fucking cave man is so
ridiculous.
I don't think it's ridiculous to think
of some sort of a device other than a
lens and a glass thing
in the front and the,
the aperture and all the words that I
don't really understand that involve
making a photograph. Those. Those
words are all alien to me. Like if you,
if you,
if I didn't know there was a camera,
I'm way too fucking stupid to
have ever thought of a camera.
I would have to live a billion lives
by myself on an island to figure out a
fucking camera and I probably still
would never figured out a good camera.
Somebody figured out that shit.
Think about that man.
When there's need,
it will be created in the future.
We're going to need to create force
fields to get these drugs out of our faces
and there microchips.
I think
there's,
I think there's a,
a crazy possibility for technological
innovation I think is it keeps getting
more and more sophisticated.
I think it's going to reach a level
that we could not imagine right now.
Just like a cave person could
never imagine wireless video.
I think it's going to reach some
bizarre molecule, some, some, some,
some such a significantly small thing
that it would be like mist and then
instead of cameras it would like transmit
a three dimensional image of all the
air around it all the time.
And then you could live inside
that three dimensional image.
Like people could live in your life and
you wouldn't even know they were there
and they would be there all the time.
Yeah,
I think we're going to get to some
super fucking bizarre shit and about 200
years, I'm thinking about 200
fucking years of this keeping up.
We're going to get to some strange
place that's remarkably similar to what
happens when you take too much mushrooms,
some bizarre intertwining
lot electronically created
psychedelic dimension that
we'll be able to share information with
each other all the time, everywhere.
See each other and it's just
a few fucking decades away.
It's going to start a little creeps and
pops and we're just going to get double.
The world's gonna get weirder
and weirder and weirder,
weirder and more of these fucking
weird fucking smiley face drones.
What's that thing called,
lily? They're going to get smaller.
They're going to be, bugs are going to be,
birds are going to be little tiny things
that fly everywhere and everyone's just
going to have to concede to going to
have to concede that there's no privacy.
Every time you get a scratch ticket, they
give you five drones. You walk outside,
you fucking throw him in the air. It's
ridiculous. The whole thing's ridiculous.
We only eat gluten.
I don't think that's what you want a
drone to follow you around. Fuck No.
Why would like, why would,
why I didn't. I'm, I'm,
it's hard enough to process
the information I'm getting by
walking around. Right? Yeah.
It's hard enough to process that with
all the things that you do in your life.
How hard is it to process the information
that you get while you're walking
around?
It's fucking hard.
Right?
That's why we can watch it in replay
from our drone video. That's ridiculous.
Cause you watch that too and you're like,
oh my God, this is what it looked like.
That's why people start
fucking with their face, man.
You know when people started doing
crazy shit and plastic surgery,
they're trying to look
glass at themselves. As bizarre
as that seems, you know it's the,
the the, the, the idea of look,
looking at yourself like rationally
you want to look less at yourself,
you want to get more wrapped up in some
crazy little tiny aspect of who you are.
Fixed that and everything will be good.
You don't want to look at
yourself like as a whole,
as an entity and you're just
doing crazy Mickey Rourke,
your style. You can make a drone
follow you how long until they can,
you can make it fall to
someone else and like someone,
you just have a thousand
[inaudible] TMZ guys phone.
We can get to some point man.
It's not that far away. Far
Way where the,
the,
the idea of privacy is
going to be preposterous.
It's we, I think it's not that far
away. I don't know how many decades.
It is a way.
What it seems to me that if I looked at
what a cell phone looks like in 2015 and
it with what it looked like
in 1989 or whatever it was,
when people first started
getting car phones,
remember they used to call them car
phones. That is not that long, man.
That's not that long in the world.
Just not in terms of like Tara doctorals
and snails and zebras and shit.
This is not that long as a little tiny
moment of time and something changed
radically. It's like everything
is worked slowly, slowly,
slowly,
slowly slow over a genetic and biological
level until this one crazy fucking
monkey figured out how to make its
own life and decided to make its own
technological life and his
technological life changes rapidly,
rapidly,
just changes all the time constantly and
it has no regard whatsoever for little
tiny mice that you have to
feed your chickens. It doesn't
give a fuck about them.
It's just trying to change and get faster
and quicker and better all the time
and that's what the Internet is and
that's what AI is and that's what these
fucking flying things
toss off a cliff are.
And what we are is the
apes clinging to the vines,
the shit slinking jungle
worried.
Oh my God, it's fucking
robots are going to take over.
How horrible would it be if we
didn't take over from the monkeys?
Could you imagine?
Could you imagine if every time you
wanted to go out to west Hollywood you had
to deal with gorillas kicking your ass.
Fucking your girl in front of you.
Gorilla racist. Yeah. Cute. Magically.
Gorillas hated people and
people hitting gorillas.
They were everywhere and there's
some sort of a protection thing.
We're trying to figure out how to work
this out. Come on son. We got lucky.
Lucky we got lucky. We
got to this point, right?
I don't know.
My original point was sure it had one.
Do you see, did you get one of these
yet? Have you seen those in person yet?
The smart scooters.
These aren't like songs,
those, I saw a guy walking on
the street with one of those yet.
Yeah, I think I might
get one but it's, it's,
it's pretty much a very
inexpensive scooter that works
like a segue to the point
where if you don't it
just balances and you use
a um, uh, a remote control
look. See, here it is right
here is an action. Uh,
it pretty much just point
this thing. Charges fast only takes
a couple hours to fully charge.
So learning to ride the scooter
is actually really easy.
You just hit the power button, gently
step on the platform, one foot at a time.
These black rubber pads or like touch
sensitive buttons turning on the motors
when enough pressures applied using a
wall or person for support and practice
standing up straight. The key is
to just stay relaxed. Pro Tip,
push your feet to the edges against the
rent, which seems to help me balance.
Then you can start leaning forwards
or backwards to move around.
And that's really it. It's so quick
and easy to learn. It's very intuitive.
You just let your brain kind of think
about moving around and I'll automatically
do it for you.
I even had my little nine year old
niece learning to ride it and just a few
minutes and about 20 minutes
in my first time practicing,
I felt very comfortable.
Well,
I don't know why it's going up and down.
It can go up hills.
You can feel the genre working underneath
your feet is very good and precise.
A lot of people in Hollywood are,
are riding around on these and it looks
so goofy when you first see it and it,
cause people are like
going in stores with,
I saw somebody the other day at Panera
bread, just ordering was standing on one.
It's amazing.
It looks a little Porsche wheels.
I got Fukes and it will Fukes
wheels. Yeah. But it's cool.
It's like reverse Fukes.
There seems to be one manufacturer
or a generic manufacturer.
It and there all of these people are
rebranding it and selling under different
names, but there's also a few that
have better wheels and go faster, uh,
on it. Wow. But, uh, it's, it's, I
can see us all having these very soon.
Like what that kind of,
how we all thought that,
that the segway was going to
take off kind of, uh, you know,
they made sidewalks for segways.
This seemed a little bit more doable
as you can get one of these for $340 on
Amazon. Yeah. It's a skateboard,
skateboard size segway that
balances brilliant. Yeah.
That's a perfect example of
like the difference between
a cell phone from 88 and
what we're putting in our pocket today.
Everybody.
Did you see that thing where there's
some hack that they can do on android
phones? Well, you just
have to send you a text.
What did you,
yeah.
Did you see the hack that the jeep had
to recall all their cars because people
could, can control the breaks, the sound,
troll the fucking car and shut it off.
Like we used to always talk about,
now it's actually happening. Whoa,
here's the article.
Right?
Porque see for Real, how long does
it take before unrecognizable?
How long does it take before human beings
become some super bizarre robot hybrid
that drives cars with his brain?
How long is it a week?
Is it a year into the,
is it a decade?
Yeah. Here it is. Uh, this is the,
the hack that led to the huge jeep.
All right. [inaudible]
um, well all these cars,
every car that has antilock brakes and
every car that has all this traction
control, a lot of that stuff
is electronically managed.
Traction control is a,
a big issue with cars.
They want to make cars
safer and easier to handle.
If one of the wheels start
skidding, they, it comes in and uh,
motor enthusiasts like guys
who are like race car drivers,
like a Chris Harris or
something like that. They, they,
they would call it like nanny devices.
Like, like, like nanny controls.
They don't want that because they
know how to drive really good.
But the most of us,
me included,
don't drive so fucking good and your
wheels start skidding out from back behind
you. I don't know exactly what to do. I
know a little bit from driving in snow,
but not like a matte fairer one of
these fucking dudes who drives cars like
professionally. That's where that
kind of electronic shit comes in.
That's what this thing is.
One and 1.4 million fiats uh,
they that during the test hackers were
able to exploit to kill the engine,
disabled the brakes and track the location
of it so they could track. You know,
when you're going around a corner
on a bridge and take off your brain,
it only makes sense because if you have a,
and that car has like satellite
gps and all that jazz, you,
you have to understand that,
that that car is being somehow or
another connected from a computer with an
Internet connection or some sort of a gps
connection that goes up to a satellite
and it's following you. That's how it
knows where you are when your, you know,
it's,
it's telling you turn right in 200 yards.
It's telling you that because
it's connected to something,
it's something knows where it is.
Right? It's figuring this out.
It's getting it from the GPS.
There's a satellite this tracking you.
It's so strange when you
think about what that is,
is that he's like,
I was driving 70 miles per hour out.
What the fuck just happened here?
I was driving 70 miles per hour on the
edge of downtown St Louis though I didn't
touch the dashboard.
The vents in the jeep Cherokee
started blasting cold air at maximum,
showing a sweat on my back
through the seat climate control.
Next switched the radio station to the
local hip hop station and blaring skee Lo
at full volume.
He didn't touch anything.
So some hackers were taking over his
car while he's in it and then, uh,
killed it on the middle of the
highway going 70 miles an hour. I,
I read a little bit this just like a test.
It's like a special test they had.
They installed something special inside
of it so that they could connect to it
also, it wasn't, oh, it was like
a random of, oh wait a minute.
So this couldn't happen with a jeep.
That's a regular GFE off a lot
unless someone went to that jeep,
installed this extra thing here.
Well, what does that extra thing?
Thumb drive probably that you
can just plug into the USB.
You know I have thumb drives him all my
stuff that know what the fuck does off
to the thumb drives are in that console.
You don't see them stick in there and
it probably is just uploading it to it.
So the thumb drive but, but
it's, see I don't know anything.
And I was going to say
enough about computers.
I don't know anything about computers.
But if you stuck a thumb drive into a car,
he couldn't.
Could it automatically access to
you drove your car?
Here's my what mine does in my f my edge.
I plug it in and then it goes, would you
like to a software update? And I'm like,
yes.
And it just hit yes.
Then updates my software in it using
something I downloaded off the internet
onto a thumb drive. Oh Wow. So this is,
these are the guys and this is actually
them showing them how it's done. Uh,
the audio is up. I don't know
why it's not playing any audio,
but Charlie's house miles away.
They wouldn't tell me what they had plans,
but they assured me that it wouldn't be
anything life threatening. Remember Andy,
no matter what happens,
don't panic.
It's not the first time I'd driven a car
while it's being attacked by these two
hackers.
But in 2013 they were in the back seat
and the laptops were wired into the
vehicle to report. In fact, oh my.
Now they're sending the same sort of
attacks remotely and I have no idea what
they might do
going as fast as I've seen him. So. So
first we're going to turn the fan on them.
Yeah, let's turn the
fan on. TV even notices.
All right. All the something just turned
on. All the fans and AC and stuff.
I didn't do that. The trick
is started small. Oh my God.
That was a picture of Charlie
and Chris and tracksuits.
But as I drove down the interstate,
things started getting
unpleasant and very loud.
Oh my God.
Videos.
Leann shinny slash brain is windshield
washer fluid and I can't see any need to
get to the windshield wiper
fluid. I mean, I do it.
Do it, kill the engine. It was
killing the engine right now.
That part that says, oh my God,
they killed it on the highway.
The calories.
I stomped on the gas,
but the jeep slowed to a crawl.
What if the car behind them
just in rear those tower,
but I turned on my hazard lights,
but I was still stuck in the right
lane with no shoulder to escape on
two guys.
Thug on the highway.
Oh, I think he's panicking. He's not
going to hear us with that radio so loud.
He's a big guy.
Big salary to go work again.
The accelerator. We'll work.
It won't work. You're doing
seriously dangerous.
I need to do
you gotta turn the car off. Okay.
Now you should be good to go,
Sam.
I drove by.
Okay, but that man, what if you were
behind them when that happened? Oh,
I know what if that's
what I was going to say.
That seemed very dangerous for them
to do that real [inaudible] front of
wired.com.
Yeah, but you're the best at figuring out
that. That's totally real. Yeah. Jamie,
Jamie's.
Kevin,
you're going to be,
I mean it could be a,
we wired would not put it on there
wired. They can let you get duped. Yeah,
wired legit went to
hear him talk my route.
No, no, that's cool. I get it. I
believe it. It's just how the fuck.
Yeah, it's scary. They shouldn't do
that. No, definitely shouldn't do that.
If you're going to do that, you should do
that on a track. You shouldn't do that.
If you want to prove it, prove it on a
track. Donald don't prove it like that.
That's crazy. Yeah. I don't know if they
really did that. If they really did that,
that seems to me to be unnecessary.
All you'd have to do is take people on
a track and have them drive around in a
controlled environment and do the same
thing and everybody would freak out.
You wouldn't have to do this.
Yeah. Not on the highway
where there's no shorter.
I think it was the people not knowing
that there wasn't a shoulder and so you
know well
also like, like what if it
was in the left lane. I mean,
maybe they made an agreement
to only stay in the right lane,
but if you were stuck out there
and someone didn't pay attention,
they were coming up behind you fast.
They couldn't hit the brakes.
[inaudible] Fuck Jenner. Fuck yeah. Yeah.
Back when Caitlin was,
Bruce sounds like a novel,
but a back when was still a
identified as Bruce. She, uh,
slammed into a car and pushed that
car into oncoming traffic. Apparently.
Fuck.
It's too easy to get in car accidents.
The idea that any person just not
paying attention for a brief moment,
Katie accidentally hit something. You
know, it's like what we're talking about.
If you just took your whole life,
have you accidentally bumping
into shit and you added it all up
to give anybody the ability to drive at
whatever speed they would like based on
how hard they push the right pedal and
make sure they hit the breaks on time.
It is remarkable how few crashes
there are. It's fucking remarkable.
It's remarkable how well
people keep it together.
If we see one accident on the
highway at a 20 million people in la,
we go fucking idiot.
The one on one should be accidents
all day long, every day, all day.
Be Cons to meet explosions or fire.
If we were really the ogres that we would
like to perceive ourselves as being,
I just fucking smashed into
each other while jerking off.
I don't think it's that
bad. Yeah man. I'm fucking,
I'm positive she hear that Twitter's
or racing stolen jokes. Yeah.
I thought that was interesting
because, um, how do they determine,
is it publishing who published it
first or who put it on Twitter,
Twitter doing it on its own system.
Here's the Twitter is erasing store and
jokes and they're putting up actual like,
you know, this uh, tweet has
been copywritten or, hmm.
Uh, well here's the thing, man. I,
I totally support it if it was accurate
all the time as far as like who was the
original creator of it.
But sometimes it seems like the history
of that stuff was too hard to track down.
The article says they have a team of
people inside their acts inside Twitter
looking at each case. Okay. So they look
at it and then they make a determination.
It matter. I guess I'll go what
happened on youtube or anywhere else?
You might have copyright issues.
Does that make sense?
Have you ever thought of something and
you thought, ah man, this is awesome,
but you realize that somebody else had
already thought of it a hundred times
like that. The thing is that,
that what makes me mad is this,
this one person who's saying that
she writes jokes for a living.
She feel Tess's jokes on Twitter
and stuff, but you know that,
so she says a joke that she thinks
that she wrote, but you know,
you see like lethal weapon two and they
use the same joke and then lethal weapon
two and you're like, oh fuck. But she,
oh, you know who says is who? I mean,
that seems like, I dunno,
but it is Twitter. Who gives
a fuck, you know? Oh No,
they deleted.
It is annoying.
Like if you wrote something that was
really hilarious about something,
it was like a particular red band asked
take on something and it was hilarious
and you put it on Twitter
or anything and it
got like all these retweets and
people are lol, lol, lol, lol, lol,
lol. Yeah. And with any saw, a bunch
of other people read like just took it.
They didn't retweet,
they just took it and put
it on their Twitter feed. He'd
been like, ah, why did you do that?
But sometimes you both
think of the same shit.
Yeah, that's possible too. It happens
more and more. It's, it's weird,
especially watching old movies they
grew up with, you know, and and going,
Oh my God,
that joke that I thought of the other
day was just because there was this one
part and this one obscure Steve Martin
movie from the 70s that I liked and it
was just a weird variation of that and
I didn't even realize it. I was like,
Holy Shit, I'm looking at their
act, the form on their website.
It's very similar to how it
happens on Youtube. Really.
All they're saying is like,
if you're willing to say that
this is a copyright infringement,
you have to be willing to
go to court for it. So,
and then Twitter's getting their
hands out of the, out of the horny.
So they're just saying like here's,
so if someone's willing to go to
court for it, then they pull it.
It says by like when you fill
out the thing, you have to,
I understand that under
17 USC section five, 12,
I am liable for any damages including
costs and attorney fees if I had knowingly
materially misrepresent that I reported
material or activity that is infringing.
See the problem is
parallel thinking is so common amongst,
especially amongst like
current events subjects.
Like there was a funny story that are
used to tell cause at the time this was
like 19,
it was either 1990,
1999 or 2000 when that
Chinese aircraft with a,
there was like a uh,
a collision or something between an
American and Chinese aircraft and the
Chinese aircraft was flown by guy
named Wong Way. Oh yeah, that's right.
I remember that. I was like
five years ago probably. No,
no, no, no, no, it was, it was,
it was 2000 because it was when I did my,
uh,
belly from the beast DVD from Texas.
And I remember like I talked about
it like I might've been, it might've,
I might've had it on that bit
or my on that special if it not,
it was in that time,
it was around that time.
But Ari was working in the cover booth
at the time and Ari was like the audience
after like five hours of Comedians,
it's like, what is this a fucking joke?
Like you just all did the same
joke over and over and over again.
And the guy's name was Wong way,
you know.
So we would all show up
like five or six guys,
Dave and you know how the store works.
Nobody pays attention to
anybody that's on before him.
You're in the back hanging out having
laughs and the guys on stage and he's
saying the same fucking joke.
She just said to him [inaudible]
as you can figure it out also
because you'll be on stage,
like I know that usually at least gets
a reaction and then you find out that Oh
yeah. To, you know, to other people
talked about boner pills or at least,
yeah, there's certain subjects. Yeah.
Well that was what we were talking
about before about stepping on stuff.
What are you going in there for? Yeah,
Coca Cola, Coca Cola, golf. Hello.
Stepping on something. One of our friends
had a, an issue with that recently,
or actually two friends, two different
friends in two different occasions.
Worked at comedy clubs and um,
they work with these local guys and
like say they did Thursday, Friday,
Saturday or something like that.
They do the Thursday with
the local guy and then on,
on Friday when they would come in,
they would do all the local
guy would do all their jokes,
but a version of them.
So like I said,
if you had a joke about Burrito's
I fucking love burritos.
That was like a big part of
your act. Well, I'll tell
you what, I'm Jamie Verdun.
I fucking love Burritos and he just
kept going on about that. Right.
They would just circumvent
that and they would,
they would make it so that they would
do some sort of a weak ass joke about
burritos. So then when you would go
up and do your joke about Burritos,
20% of the air would be
left out of the sales.
This is a shitty example cause
burritos is very rare for her.
I just had to happen to me,
Joe, I just had to have,
I had it where the guy was even said,
I'm just turned 41 man.
I like eating ass now I tell you. And
I'm like, I'm about to go on stage.
And that's the first thing I'm saying,
it's about gym. I'm telling you,
just cock blocked her own
self. Jesus Christ. Listen,
put your headphones on so you listen
to what you said. It doesn't matter.
We'll Diaz had it happened to two.
It happens man. It's fucking stupid.
Yo. The young guys that do
it, I know what they're doing.
They're just trying to get ahead.
They're trying to do well, but it's a,
it's one of the worst ways you
could ever work with somebody.
So it's such a short sighted way
of thinking about things too.
You gotta circumvent and
sabotage their act. That's why
you do it. Right. You know,
you always bring everybody you know on
the road and so you don't have to deal
with that shit ever. Well, do it
right there too, because also,
I know that's going to be an awesome show.
Like we've got a show in Austin,
Texas on August 29th Ian
Edwards, Joey Diaz in me. Wow.
Bet The house.
Even if I suck
in Edwards and Joey Diaz
are two motherfuckers.
That is insane show.
Those guys are good man.
Ian Is fucking funny. I love and it's
great. I just watched him the other day.
He's like,
I never watched comedy,
but I really sat down and
watched his set the other day.
I laughed harder than I've laughed
in awhile. He's a good dude too, man.
Thing about Ian.
He's a really good dude.
He's just like calm and smooth and
friendly, you know, great stage presence.
Oh my God. Dude, he murders it.
I don't want to do any of his bits
because I don't want to ruin it for you.
But some of his bits are so smooth.
He just like halfway into the bit,
you close your eyes like,
ah,
as a punchline hits you like
a wave of Oh shit. Oh Shit.
Oh no, he didn't. Uh,
he's so different. I love,
well, I've known him forever.
I've been friends with Ian's. It's
like, um, I, uh, I started in the 88,
I think I came to New York in [inaudible]
91, somewhere around there and that's,
I met Ian somewhere around them.
He's always been the same dude,
always been super cool.
It's just like somewhere along the line,
I know he figured out how to just become
so funny. He just started nailing it.
And like,
especially
in La, uh, he's one of those
dudes, like if he's onstage,
I make a point to go see him.
I'm always make a point to go see Ian.
He's always got some new shit and halfway
into his new shit. You going, ah, ah, ah,
no, no, no, no, no, no. Oh No, you didn't.
He's funny.
Yeah.
Do you know a, a guy named Dan Saint
Germain? Have you ever heard of him? No,
I think so. Where's it from? Uh, I
think he's from here. He lives here.
I am. I know him by face.
I might not know his name.
I had on my secret or a comedy show
the other day and he destroyed like,
I've never seen somebody destroy.
He seems like one of those guys,
it was hot and he had a jacket on
and he has a full beard and he just,
and he destroyed like,
and he,
he felt like he was
closing the whole time.
And this dude before I
definitely slipped high.
We should get them on the [inaudible].
He's hilarious guys.
Listen man, that's beautiful.
That's beautiful. Love that guy.
We're always going to have these guys.
They're always going to,
they're not going to stop.
They're going to be more now.
There's going to be more than,
I think there's more to that.
Like I was having this conversation
with Diaz and with, uh,
Adam from the comedy
store and we were like,
I go when I look around guys
like [inaudible] and Chris
Rock and Dave Chappelle
and Louis C K and I just,
and Diaz and uh,
Dunkin and Ari and Jim Jeffries.
And I am like,
fuck man,
this is my favorite comedy era ever.
This is my favorite as far
as like the shit that I like.
Like this is my favorite. I could
listen to these guys forever as a comic.
Um,
you know,
we're a part of this weird new
sort of next level of comedy.
There's a lot of like amazing
artists that are popping up now. Man,
there's a lot of really fucking
funny people that are popping up now.
Thompson Gora is funny as fuck dude.
I had him on the Ice House show two weeks
ago and he was discharged Roy Yang in
the back of the room at one point in time.
I was like,
I remember meeting Tom on that. Eddie,
uh, excuse me, Charlie Murphy, uh,
John Heffron Gig that I did in Phoenix
and he was so composed and it's so
smooth. Yeah. The real minute comedy
tour. So smooth. And I remember thinking,
Holy Shit,
this guy is fucking funny.
But that was like 2005 or something
like that or whatever the hell it was.
Or six when you look at
this like w who he is now,
God damn dude, he's, he's a machine.
He's up there killing the
other night I was like,
Holy Fuck Thompson girls on another level,
man.
What, what is it? Cause it
seems like he really found,
he really found his voice
quick. Like I, it seems like,
uh, I've known him, you know,
maybe eight years,
nine years or whatever,
and I met him in San Francisco or I
actually had met him on the tour also.
But it seems like recently
he's just in a whole different
level.
It's,
it's so interesting seeing comics go
like up a level in front of your eyes.
Like Ari did that Ari, I saw Ari special
and it's probably one of the I, I,
I was amazed. I was like, I can't believe
you did that. Like that was perfect.
I hadn't seen him in two years ago.
He, he got that different in two years,
you just kept working and kept pushing.
It's amazing. It's amazing to watch,
you know, even though you know it's going
to happen again every time it happens.
It's like if you were watching a flower
and you watched it every day and you
slowly got used to the fact that it's
slowly opening up at at a certain point in
time, you walk by that same spot and
you see that flower and you go, Oh shit.
Meanwhile, am I calling Aria Flower? Yes.
My beautiful chew flower.
He,
I'm just figured it out, man.
He's a smart dude. You know,
always got this way of looking at the
criticism and the praise and figuring out
which ones are right and
just fucking plowing ahead.
They just figured it out.
He's figured out how to get better
and figured out how to be stronger.
I figured out how to write better.
I figured out how to kill on stage and
he just got this crazy point where he's
at now. Do you know about the men? Most
of producer Paradiso, I think it's called.
It's called the sensitive plant.
It's this really trippy plant that when
you touch it, it like moves and opens up.
Kind of like, like if you're scratching
the back of a cat or something like that,
it's really trippy. Uh, it's very
sensitive. Like, look, he just, you know,
touching it moves. Yeah. Whoa. And
then there's even parts where like,
it will curl up. Ooh, this is bizarre.
So he's touching it and these,
these leaves are actually retracting,
like they're sad. Closing up. Yeah.
And then you can also rub it and it will
kind of move towards the way of your
hand and like,
isn't that neat?
God Damn Dude, it's a, in Brazil,
Brazil's got all the crazy shit.
They've got that spider that
gives you a boner till you die.
Brazilian wandering spider.
Yeah. You know that one.
That's the one that gives you a boner and
it makes it, if you survive the poison,
which you probably won't, it'll
destroy your deck. So Dick's blown out.
That's ridiculous. Like a hotdog.
I wonder if they can dilute it.
Have we already talked about this? I
wonder if we could download it. Well,
they're trying to, they're certainly
working on it, but believe me,
they thought about it too.
Like I'm an idiot if I know that.
It makes you get harder on
women by scientists know to,
it's a thing now, a woman,
if I, Agora is a thing now. Well I
thought regular Viagara they use on women,
didn't they? Don't they use that on women?
I don't know. I don't want it enough.
This one vibrates flag
palsy.
It gives you some sort of
epilepsy. Yeah, I think that uh,
there's going be a lot of different
drugs they get from stuff like that.
I just can't wait to have something
where women take to get more horny.
I think that's going to change it. I think
it's a game changer. Drying solution.
He's like, I'm not getting
more attractive. So listen,
we're going to figure out
how to work at the other way.
Feel cause we could have just
waited. He fucked her. I was,
I didn't do it to themselves. Yeah.
It would have been free and clear. No,
no hard feelings at all. I mean, um,
did you see the snoop dog shit? Yeah,
it's fucked up. He's never going
to go to Sweden again. Does that,
does that worry you? Cause you
could have Sweden her life. No,
I've only been there once.
I think you went there,
but I enjoyed it and I
was sober. Um, Jesus.
But he was driving though.
That's kind of weird that he was
actually driving in Sweden. Yeah.
I don't know the story. Is that
what happened? He's driving Jamie.
He's accusing the Swedish
police of racially profiling
him after he was detained
in the town of Uppsala racially.
I think there are a little
bit different with a race.
I wonder how much so in Sweden
than they are in America.
Somebody I'd known it was
snoop to like Florida or Texas.
They pullover tour buses. Knowing
who wiz Khalifa, Willie Nelson,
people involved in arrests
in the same area. Right? Huh.
Huh?
I have no idea.
Maybe it's like his Negro,
a bad word still.
Is that where he's like still on the
fence? That's a good question. It may be,
I just fucked up by saying it.
So I don't think it's bad,
but it's just tasteful,
tasteful.
You know what's weird is that like the
difference between colored and people of
color,
it's like
it's such a small difference
between those two phrases.
Colored is offensive, right? You
say colored people it's offensive.
But if you say people
of color not offensive,
it's colored people really offensive that
if you call it two Mexicans, Asians, US,
anyone. Yeah, because they don't, they
don't like it. It doesn't, you know,
it's like the idea is there's regular
people and then there's colored people.
Right. So it may, it's like a distinction.
I like how Mexicans own the word
Brown now they're like, yeah,
I'm Brown and like we'll, they're
allowed to get away with Brown pride.
That's like a big source of contention
in the mixed martial arts community.
Cause Cain Velasquez who was the UFC
heavyweight champion until he just lost to
uh, uh, for ratio for doom.
He has brown pride tattooed on his
chest and he's widely recognized.
It's not if not the all time great.
One of the all time great
heavyweight fighters ever.
And he has brown pride and
someone had said, you know,
a bunch of people said what would happen
if a guy was the heavyweight champion
like Brock Lesnar and he had white
pride on his chest. Like Whoa,
you're not allowed to have white pride.
Like that's,
you have to have only like it has to
be minorities. If it's, it's weird.
It's like I get it because it's like the
dominant white pride has been sort of
like automatically attached in our,
our idea with like the KKK or like some
crazy fucks that hate black people.
Whereas like with Brown part Brown pride,
we sort of have this idea like
automatically they just are happy
and proud. They're proud
people. They're proud to be
Mexican. It's okay. It's weird.
Right? It's very weird. It's weird,
but it's understandable. I mean,
totally makes sense to me. I'm not. I
just want to be really clear about that.
I'm not arguing against that
at all. I get it. I wouldn't,
I wouldn't hesitate for a second to think
that someone with a white pride tattoo
on the chest might be racist. I would. I
would. I would immediately go, oh Jesus.
If I was walking down the beach and some
dude was coming towards me and he had
white pride tattooed on his chest, I'd be
like, oh, confederate flag. Same thing.
Only difference between the confederate
flag is that the confederate flag for a
lot of people,
as ridiculous as it is represented
their love of the south.
I think that the idea of having this
rebel flag that also represented people
that wanted to keep slavery regardless
of all the economic arguments,
and I'm too fucking stupid to understand,
but you know,
and I know everybody knows you taught.
You start talking about the, the,
the generally and the dukes
of hazard and that fucking,
that rebel flag on the roof of it.
Everybody connects that with
the south in the civil war,
the war against the north that they lost.
And that's what created all of us.
We're all Americans now.
Okay.
This idea that you're still the south
and you have to have this fucking
different flag and I get that.
It would be fascinating,
but the idea that it's cool to just fly
that fucking thing in the State House.
It's crazy. It's crazy. It's bananas.
And even though I joked around
about it on Instagram, about a,
I did a whole post
about it, about the, uh,
the idea is ridiculous because the real
flag on that show was the daisy Duke
cause I was like,
daisy Duke represented a flat,
it was like the first time there was a,
an a,
a piece of clothing that let the world
know that you're hungry for Dick,
whether your slots are gay men,
if you wearing those cutoff shorts.
But that was my only reason for doing it.
I don't want,
I don't really have a political statement
and defensive keeping the flag in the
general Lee.
I think if you could have a fucking
dude with a laptop that can pretend that
he's jumping over cars in
the middle of the street,
turn that stupid flagging to into an
American flag. Let's joke around about it.
You know,
one point in time that flag used to be
the rebel flag of the rebel army that
fought in the civil war against the north
and loss. Can you believe that shit,
but now look at it. Oh, glory. Hold
Gloria.
I never ever thought anything about
racism growing up with that flag.
I thought it was a cool looking for lag.
I thought it was the flag from the Dukes
of Hazzard. I went to Williamsburg.
You would see that flag everywhere.
As a kid.
You were taught that flag like whatever.
It's the flag north south flag
you'd set by at the souvenir shop,
but I don't think it was ever taught to
us. It has any connections to racism.
I think that's just cause we were
too young and stupid. Stupid. Right?
But you're right, man. I used to
love the fucking dukes of Hazzard.
Everybody I know love the Dukes of
hazard. That show was the shit. Yeah,
just the Google home born and you
know that we'll be back there.
It's just going to take them to a couple
of months to track the American flag on
it. You know, repaint it. CGI style. I
hope they do. I mean, I don't know man.
Obviously I have a point
of view of a white guy,
point of view of a white guy when
it comes to shit like slavery.
So I always like, it's a, you
know, say hi. Say what you feel,
but recognize it's not about your people
and it wasn't really that fucking long
ago. 1865 what does that, yeah,
that ain't shit. You know,
when you know, you know you're having
a birthday show August 5th right?
How old are you going to be?
41 think about that shit.
I think about 1865 it ain't shit.
It ain't shit. It ain't shit.
That shit was yesterday.
They had slaves, dude,
I'm 47 I'm going to be 48 in August.
The slaves were like a day before
I was born. They had slaves.
That's fucking stupid,
man.
It was to literally 200 years
before I was born. That is nothing.
That's nothing.
That's not that much time.
I remember a hundred years
before I was born is crazy.
Had fucking slavery two years before that.
That's real,
right? 1865 I was born in 1967 so
literally a hundred years. 200 years.
A hundred years ago. 200 years ago.
There was slavery everywhere, right?
It was commonplace 300 years ago.
400 years ago. What is 400 years?
If you live to be 100 that's
that's, you know, that's awesome.
That's like the best you get,
so your life and his life back
to back is slavery everywhere.
If you live the full potential of Jamie
and the full potential of red band back
to back, birth to death, and
that's slavery everywhere.
Not even an argument against it. It's
just fucking a part of doing business.
That's not that long ago at all.
Think about the idea of 1865
okay.
That's bananas. The Beatles were
less than a hundred years later.
Less than a hundred years after
the Beatles, or excuse me,
before the Beatles, there was slavery
less than a hundred years after slavery.
You have the Beatles. How? How not
is that 1865 think about that, right?
Was it 70 65 what year was it?
What? What years of civil war?
What do you do that as you forget
we hear was forward.
What year was that guy? 1921 no, for that.
Is it like sixties sixties or
seventies when you were at Gerald Ford.
Gerald Ford? No, not the cars. The
Ford. Gerald. Well, it's a Nixon.
Nixon was a seventies right?
Yeah. Thinking about that guy,
sixties in the 70s what was the year a
Kennedy died in [inaudible] 63 correct?
Is that right? Somewhere around
then Johnson. Okay. Kennedy,
then Johnson and then Nixon after
him. Yeah. Is that what happened?
And then Carter? Yeah, dairy
again. That's not that long.
Q magic.
Richard Nixon ran for president today.
TV show 30 something.
I used to think that those people are old.
Oh my God are dead. They were dead.
I was in high school. I was like,
this poor folks are dead.
That was,
now I'm 40 41 and a couple of weeks.
30 something that's so
depressing. Um, Sandra Bullock,
it's signaling insane. 45 older. 51 what?
That crazy. Wow. What happened
there? Life. It waits for no man.
Brian Red Ban waits for no man.
How bizarre is that?
It's weird.
A year is in our eyes.
A long time. They used to be,
I don't think of it anymore.
Listen on that long man.
I mean, I checked my mail
four times a year, so it's,
it's just for male sessions for me,
the idea of 10 years,
it used to be so big. It's an
it happens quick. I would do,
I would definitely, she's beautiful.
Beautiful. Don't say that.
What you would do to her sexually because
that's gross. She say she's beautiful.
She's hiding her man, so she's hiding.
Your hands are hands. That might change.
It might be she might've been in the
middle of some sort of a dance when she
spreads her hands out. Why? But they start
from behind her. Women get weird hands.
It goes to the first to go is their hands.
You didn't need to get checks to work
gloves now fetishists weird checks like
harnesses and shit.
She's still beautiful. But it is weird
that you realize as you get older,
how quick a year is then how
quick 10 years is and 10 20,
30 40 ch ch,
ch the differences,
we're able to access more information
than any generation before us.
So I think because of that overload,
we're looking at all this different
shit like people that we knew and loved
growing up that are dying and we go,
oh,
this is a weird little fucking crazy
ride that everybody's on here that nobody
really seems to be paying attention
to exactly how this thing works.
And no one's even really totally,
completely aware of it
until like fairly recently,
like within the last few hundred years
of life. Have you, did you see it?
I saw this thing, uh, yesterday
when I was looking online.
It's a visualization of why time seems
to be faster as you get older and it's
based just on math, like as when you're
to your reference of a year. Right.
As long as you get older, I'll show
it to you. No, it totally makes sense.
I've seen that before, but yeah,
put that up right here. Oh,
and whole life in a timeline.
Oh, okay. That makes sense.
Like when you're all the way at
17 there was a small Saul fractal.
Yeah. Scariest shit. Yeah. I mean,
I guess it is, but if you said
earlier, like you said earlier,
you know that you think that when you
die it's going to be like, Oh yeah,
I'm okay. Oh, here I am again. If that's
the case, what are we worried about?
But we are, we don't know.
We definitely don't know.
But the interesting thing is it's, for
some people it's just like not knowing,
so is too much. It's
too fucked up. You know?
That's where I think things like that
Mirage men show that we were talking about
earlier.
I think what that is is the same thing
that's like some ridiculous hardcore cult
kind of religion. The need to believe
in something that's bigger and better.
The need to believe in something that's
above all of this that you see in front
of you. Something bigger and crazier.
It's Sorta like legitimizes existence,
you know? But if there
really are aliens, right?
If there really were aliens are coming
here from another planet and they weren't
even talking to us,
like how needy our way we keep reaching
out to these fuckers that don't even
want to talk.
Tours were probably super annoying.
It won't stop calling
me. They're like, listen,
I picked up one of them in 1950 to
this day. It's a fucking industry.
Okay? Everywhere you look,
there's websites dedicated.
They make documentaries and
books and it's all lies.
Except one guy told one fucking guy,
keep his mouth shut. He couldn't do it.
I touched his butt. So whatever. Now
it's a part of the fucking folklore.
They always touch your butt and they're
always doing things to your asshole,
right? That's the whole thing.
They say they do anal probes.
That's the whole thing.
I was drunk.
One Dude who flew here from
another planet and found out where,
oh fucking country filled with rats were
a guy or a civilization that kinky bomb
mouse.
Shucked it was an experience.
We shared together a magic wand,
a cold steal table,
a bright light, a wad in your ass hole.
All right, this is what we're doing.
We're checking you out.
I want to see what you're made out of.
What do you like and what
happened became a whole thing.
Do you think it's weird when birds do
this kind of shit where they all sit like
flock together in these huge crazy
like it's like crop circle in the sky.
This seems like to me something that's
like, I don't know, like a, a mistake,
like a glitch in our universe
where birds can do these weird,
it's like they're all
falling the same program.
Like I think their power went out and
they're resetting or something like that.
Well the crazy thing is that exists
and all in nature. Yeah, fish do it.
Beautiful Way.
Fish do it just like this.
And the difference between
the birds and the fish.
Obviously he's the birds can land,
the fish have to kind of keep moving.
But some of the fish videos of
these giant schools of fish,
they look exactly like this. Right? Yeah.
Don't though, for the audio listeners,
we're what we're actually watching where
you see a humongous amount of birds.
This case, it's, I think
starlets I think they're called.
What's the name of this video?
Jamie?
Brian's planet is called watch starlings,
a spectacular murmur.
They're called Mermaid Moravians
when murmuring creations.
Murmuration if you Google that,
you can see a lot of cool
photos and stuff like that.
Murmuration numerations yeah.
And uh,
it's just weird that it seems like
the birds are all doing it. Like,
like almost like a program like that.
It doesn't seem like, it's like,
like they're just kind of following a
pattern that they're supposed to follow.
The ants do that too.
And a with ants when one of their members
dies, I think it's the queen. Yeah.
Pretty sure it's the queen.
They have an ant death spiral where they
don't know where to go. Yes, it is. Ants.
Yeah. Pull up ant death spiral, Jamie.
That is the most bizarre shit ever
because there's somehow or another file
following each other.
There's a scent or something that
they're looking for and they can't find,
and when they can't find it,
they all just keep walking in a circle
until they fucking shit the bed.
Oh, there's just explained. Is it an
explanation? There is another video where,
can we play the explanation
or would it be like copper up?
Give him a credit for whatever it is.
What is the discovery
channel or discovery channel?
It says aunt death circles explained this.
James Williams discovery news in a spiral.
It's bizarre and we wanted to
find out exactly what's going on.
We should talk Usta Research,
Hurricane Sandy,
that different than a hurricane going on
in this video is we have an
look at that. That's a
hurricane. Yeah. Yeah.
Have you [inaudible] it's Tony went
to check it. Hurricane that's crazy.
Amp is following the trail
pheromone that trail chemicals.
Wow. So it's a smart
and they've got, yeah,
during rounds so that they're following
endlessly their neighbors. Now,
the problem we have is
that army answer blind and
these are,
and they are very dependent
on following trails,
also ready to spin around
so they starve to death.
Why do we believe these people though?
He does.
What a fucking hands thinking this thing,
you can't even see it so small.
But this guy's like, no, I got it. He
knows the smell. It's the smell. Well,
they've done a lot of studies on ants.
Don't make any mistake about it.
I'm sitting there with doing
a questionnaire. Yes, no,
you know what I just said that they did
a lot of studies on the answer and I'm
assuming they've done a lot of studies
on it or just believing these guys that
smoke a lot of weed that Ha, let's
make it a smell thing. No, I have a,
you know,
it's like all these studies,
you look at some of these studies and
you're like, oh, that must be the truth.
And you find out,
oh they forgot to do this.
So now that makes that study 100%
fake in a, you know, like, uh,
there's a lot of studies where they
just didn't test the right thing and uh,
you know, later in life
they find like, oh,
we should have tested for this other
chemical and that makes that whole study
vat a void, you know? Uh, definitely
does happen all the time. I
don't know of any examples.
Well, I could do, I don't
want to even bring it up. I,
I don't want to break it
up by that teaches college.
Yeah. The way of explaining things just
yeah. No, you've got a good point though.
Never know they, they learn
new shit all the time. Right.
There's always some new
stuff that invalidates all
the stuff they used to think
for. There's a lot of wacky shit they
used to believe in not that long ago.
We find out about medicine and all
the weird shit that people used to do.
Just not that.
I think vitamin C,
like I think,
didn't they say something recently
where they thought vitamin C was the,
the the number one go to like if you
to build up your immune system and,
and stuff like that for you.
Yeah, but I thought there
was also studies. I go, nope,
we, we thought that's not completely
right. Or like drinking wine every day.
I think there's,
there's like so many like these studies
that are like that where like, no,
a glass of wine, it's really good for
your heart. And then they find out like,
like two years, Larry. Oh No,
we ever wrong. My are bad. We,
it's actually really thought it was,
the resveratrol from the glass of
wine was actually proven to work.
I'm just using that as an eight January.
Yeah.
Maple and making one up.
Yeah. Yeah. Well they,
they definitely learned shit all the
time. It wouldn't obviously, I mean,
when you look at all the medical
breakthroughs they're making at a Dale,
you've seen the new penis thing.
They're going to be a little to build
you a new penis within five years.
I'm good. But could you imagine that?
Get my penis taken out? Well, okay.
Five years they start
with regular size decks.
How long before they start getting crazy,
if they can actually make you a dick,
like,
and the idea is that you have injured
your Dick and some sort of a mechanical
accident mouth.
So sort of a industry job here,
working on machines and whatever.
But if you hang in there for five years,
they can actually make you a new deck,
right. Printed deck. I'm sure. I
don't know what they're going to do,
how they're going to do it,
but they think within five years
you'll be able to make you a deck.
So there will be no more micro penises.
So all those poor fuckers
that got just the, you know,
it's a really got to be a giant bummer
man to be born with this like tiny, tiny,
tiny, tiny, tiny deck. And a lot
of people are not any mom bench.
Not Anymore.
Now they got a dick like Thor.
How big do you think Thoratec has
to do plays? Thor thick, thick,
thick, like a fucking 10
year old weightlifters leg.
Oh yeah, I'm surprised. People with small
dicks aren't more child molesters. Right?
Write that down.
Like child molesters should
10 year old weight lifters,
leg child molesters you think
would be all about like, uh,
the small Dick people would
all be about child molesters,
I guess.
I don't know.
Right? Like if you had a really
small Dick and, and that you're,
your only thing would be Asian
girls and children or something.
I don't know what the fuck I'm
talking about. Yeah, please.
I'm trying to get you to hold the
ball while I write this thing down.
Don't throw it in the
fucking ocean. Uh, the, uh,
AP added 550,000 old knee
newsreel clips to youtube.
So all these, uh, old school news
clips, I've just been added to youtube,
like old school stuff.
Uh, which is Kinda cool.
They have a video right now showing all
the different stuff and we're talking
like, like, uh,
that you're allowed to use
and post up on, uh, things.
Can you guys open? Yeah, it's open
now. They have video archive at Apa.
So you have all these old school,
raw,
uncut videos that are now just all thrown
on youtube now. So that's kind of cool.
You get to see some, some old
shit. That's incredible. Yeah.
Elvis stuff.
Uh,
well you can embed into your website.
That's insane.
Wow.
What's insane really is when you think
about how much access to visual history
we have compared to any,
any race ever or any civilization ever.
The difference being the difference
between writing stuff down on parchment.
Would that, do you ever see that Marco
Polo show from a Netflix now Marco Polo.
It's good. Fuck on show dude. It's
one of those Netflix originals.
Does that take place in a pool?
Huh?
No, no. It takes place. Uh, and the,
the uh, the Gingiss con days king,
his cons. I think his grandson cooler con,
I think it was his son or his grandson,
but it's all about the Mongols
and Marco Polo too. It's crazy.
It's wild. It's amazing. It's
really fucking good show. It's fun.
It's fun to watch what we talking
about that maybe bring that up. Photos,
video, visual history, like
think about like their,
when they would read their history
and they read their history,
they have these fucking scrolls,
they pull out. It says the pawn,
the seventh day of the ninth month,
you know,
Cesar walk towards the water,
drank upon it and found the fish that
contain the disease that killed the city.
I mean the,
you had a fucking sit around the campfire
and guess what the fuck happened?
You had to guess what the fuck happened
just two, three generations ago.
We could look back at
video from World War One.
We can watch film footage
from World War fucking one.
We can watch world war two Vietnam. We
can watch guys smoke pot out of shotguns.
We can watch shit from Iraq.
We could see night vision footage
from Iraq and Afghanistan to,
we've seen more shit visually than any
race that's ever existed ever than any,
any civilization ever.
And not by a small amount.
By an enormous amount.
Yes.
This is a little kid.
This is a nine year old smoking tobacco
and going off on cursing and stuff like
that and not Iraq. Really. Yeah.
Can we know what she's saying?
This is on live like right now.
And I think they had some translate it
in the comments.
She might be just talking about how Mickey
Mouse and his weight cuter than Daffy
Duck.
We don't even know what it says.
Nine year old Arab smokes
and curses nonstop. So uh,
in the people in the comments
that some people have actually uh,
translate it so I don't want to read
it. Get us killed. Right. Be careful.
She seemed like she was a fervent
believer of something. These photos,
those are these birds making different
shapes and stuff like that there.
It's beautiful. It's almost like
an art piece and it's insane.
It makes me wonder what if there's
something more to that. Well, it,
it also looks like certain wavelengths
I feel like capture like radio
wavelengths you ever see like, like
images or interpretations of wavelength?
Yes.
Wavelengths and fish.
Schools of fish and schools of birds.
It's kind of like crop circles at school.
Birds, no. Oh Fuck, fuck Jesus Christ.
It's kind tired of natural crop
circles and not the fake one.
You know what I mean? Like it's
like, here's the thing, why?
Who the fuck is making crop circles
and look, stop being a dick.
Just come out and let all these dummies
know that you made all these designs and
do it again. I think they have, I
think we just haven't caught up.
So they have some, right? They have
some, they definitely have some,
but there's some of them that they don't
want to give up how they made them.
That's my interpretation.
I mean there's some fucking people that
have dedicated their life towards the
mystery of the crop circle.
Have you ever seen it?
Secrets in the field
is a documentary on it.
Mysteries in the field that he did it.
What if we find out big foot did
it all even even if they do do it.
You imagine if like that's the
coolest shit you could show us. Oh,
we knew it was still on grows.
If you come from another planet,
you fucking step on our food.
You Dick.
You know they don't do tree circles.
You know we can't eat trees. All right,
fuck you. See if sue, we have
enough houses do a tree circle,
but don't be fucking step in our
food, right? It'll crush our wheat.
You douchebag those. Turn our corn
and some fucking picture of you.
Who Dick. Right, right. Build a,
build a house for a homeless person
tonight that instead come on asshole.
Help the community out. Yeah. Why do you,
why do you have to show me some
cryptic fucking stupid message?
Too dumb to send me a text.
Hey Dude. Hey red band.
It's popped the alien.
Hey listen man.
Have you ever thought about moving
to Alaska? You might take it easy.
It's a little messages like that.
Don't fucking talk about impending doom.
Write it down inside wheat.
What will send me a text message to find
out that that we had been talking to
aliens for the whole time and they're
just like the evil people on Youtube.
Like the bad commenters and the negative
people. They're actually the alien.
It's like fuck you. Like they're
just trolling. This could be,
and that's why we think like how dumb is
this person? Why is this person so mean?
Why is that person so, yeah,
it's a fucking alien somewhere.
How about this in might not
even be the trolling us.
It might be that they were created
by the aliens, [inaudible] fathers,
their components in a
mathematical equation to sort
of push life along and the
components are really fucking annoying
stupid people and they would just keep
you moving forward to try to get
out of the way these retards.
And that's why you push further.
And that's why we have like those
Honda Atvs and shit like that.
That's why people have chainsaws.
You want to be able to push further
into the woods away from these fuckheads
could be possible. Right.
To them and thinking, man,
doing a lot of thinking lately come
up with shit like that. That's right.
Like sense. Right. Totally makes sense.
MMM.
What else? What else we got here
that I wanted to talk about? Uh,
the android phone thing.
Oh,
seaworld has oracle week to
see seaworld needs to just
stop, just stop talking. You know,
like if every time they open
their mouth about stuff like that,
every time they say something like,
you know,
wherever an oracle week
or something like that,
you're just opening yourself up for
this wave of negative publicity.
Have you seen the commercials
lately where they're like, well,
you have not captured a way all
in 28 years. We talked about it,
man, it's, we talked about one
of the shows and I was like, wow,
imagine if that was slavery.
Yeah.
Imagine if you said that we haven't
slaved a black van and over 35 years of
slaves we have here are all old fucked
up slaves that we won and a card game and
wild bill Hickok saloon. Yeah, it's rude.
It's rude and it's fucked up. It's
just, we just don't understand them,
but it's just amazing that they
don't realize that like they,
they should be trying to get out.
Like this is a toxic business you're in.
If you figured out how to be the,
the head of seaworld,
you could figure out a better way to
handle it. There's another way to do it.
There's another way to help
those things and conserve and,
and make it so that it's some
sort of a wildlife attraction.
Maybe perhaps work to engineer an
ecosphere where these animals are very
comfortable and you can do trips out
there to them and make it like a bigger
deal.
Like a Jurassic Park type.
Yeah. When did they create the
formula of c road? How long?
I see road Benanna women are
allowed to work yet. Like what? How
like the SEC 60 where they
ran out of people slavery.
So they went right to sea world.
I don't know. What if there
was a connection, it's a,
it's going to be, you know,
like Amber Lyon says they're gonna
end up on the wrong side of history.
That's a great expression.
She loves to use the wrong side of
history is a perfect way to describe this.
Like I,
you know,
just abandoning all guilt and blame
and all that. Let's just forget it.
Just forget it.
Let those fucking things go.
Just figuring out a way to let them go.
Figure out a way to engineer an enormous
bay where you can sort of keep them
nearby. Figure out a way to supply
them with food on a regular basis.
Figure out a way to communicate
with that with them.
Figuring out a way how to educate them
to get strong enough so they can start
hunting on their own.
Figure out a way how make it work because
the idea that you can take this super
intelligent being that might be as smart
as a person and the only way we could
ever enjoy that they're here is to put
them in a fucking swimming pool or the
fact that the people that enslave
them also love the ones that are free.
All right, you can't do it. I get
it. You're stuck. I get you're stuck.
You're backed into a corner by
the arguments you've made before.
You can't keep doing it. You can't
keep doing it. It's too fucked up.
Those things are smart as shit.
They just don't have fingers.
They don't have pens. They don't.
They don't print newspapers.
They don't leave behind a record, but
they're smart as shit. We know they are.
The idea that we're more important than
them to the point that we could put them
in a fucking fish tank or a swimming pool
or whatever the hell you want to call
those things. It's crazy. It
just doesn't make any sense.
They got to stop the idea that they
can keep doing this and that we don't,
you know,
we don't get completely outraged on
a regular basis that people are still
willing to go there.
Stop going there,
can't put dolphins in jail for
no fucking reason. Says wrong.
I think they're,
it's,
it's coming to the point where now
it's going to be illegal. I mean, look,
we started with transgenders
and then we went, you know,
dolphins in like 10 years.
We're going to fire and
transgender people to dolphins.
I'm just saying that there's,
in 10 years it's going to think you
make some awesome points to, hey,
have you checked out Paulie?
Tune a on he,
he's the one that always makes all
the cartoons based on the show.
He just released a new one,
the ranch one, Jesus Christ.
Talented as fuck, man. You want to
show a little bit of that? Yeah.
Well let's end with do
we have enough time to,
and with that it's about just
enough time to enlist. All right.
Goodnight everybody. A red
band. Uh, thanks for doing
this. There's a lot of fun.
We went to old school tonight, San
Jose, it might be there Thursday.
So as Dean and Dean del Rey and
Christian Spicer at the San Jose Improv.
So come out to do, we haven't done these
in forever. I know. It's fun holds.
Cool. All right, we're gonna play this
Paulie tune and then go fuck yourself.
I'll be back tomorrow with uh,
Chris and Carrick from mixed martial
arts.com the guys who created it and run
mixed martial arts.com. Exciting
Shit. Pitch Reebok and a,
how dare you. And we're going
to, uh, right now. Play this
and then get outta here.
All right. Thank you everybody. Thanks
everybody to came up to Chicago.
We had a great time.
Thank you.
You see guys much love. Bye
Bye. [inaudible] find the ranch.
You can't find the ranch one.
Yeah.
Are you still, are we still on the
air? Right by, by big kiss you fuck.
And we still in the air right before the
way you put on like really hitting on
mercury fillings in his mouth.
Just just look for blue
cheese with wings.
Go Fuck your mother.
All right. All right. You
Ready? Let's go. Okay,
crank out. That's China. That's
already in China. I this is, it's an,
I have it on mine.
Oh,
I don't have it off.
Yesterday I was saying how Joey
d will get mad about ketchup
because there'll be wanting to come up
with this fucking Heinz Ketchup or ranch.
Have you ever heard,
been
talking about ranch? Oh, fucking hate
rant. Fuck. People could eat that shit.
I don't know how people could eat ranch.
I like when I go to a place and I say,
you all, you have wings and
they say cubs with rent.
I get up and leave even
if I don't get the wings.
Because if you're going
to serve wings ranch,
I don't want to do business with you,
but I want to do business with you.
I'm very easy. I'm very fucking easy.
So if you fucked up pork fried rice,
what do we got to talk about? Wings must
be done with blue cheese. Blue Cheese.
Yeah, like the way that
they invented in Buffalo,
New York and you got to do something.
Whatever original you're going
to show up with that rant.
That's most like somebody says you have
a small branch is starting to replace
ketchup. Yeah, that's good.
If you're a fucking hillbilly and you
want the taste of ass in your mouth,
don't fucking debt. I hate
that fucker. Read Shit.
Don't put it close to me and I'll put it
around me and see the blue cheese with
wings and go fuck your mother. That's
the next year. All right, please.
You're going to give me a fucking low.
I'll ranch with fuck away. I can say, Ooh,
Jesus. Fuck your mother.
Go fuck this shit.
Fucking got to give me
branch with my wings.
Let tell you mother fuckers.
I'm stoked. The fucking
cheeses.
Wigs.
You go fuck your mother fucking
getting into ranch shit.
I mean like people around the a ranch
like don't order that shit around me.
Do me that favor. All Right, ladies and
gentlemen, this fucking podcast is over.